one practical use case for artificial
intelligence is healthcare imaging if
you're interested in the fields of
machine learning or artificial
intelligence this is a great course for
you mohammed who is a computer vision
phd student will teach you how to use
pytorch and monae for automatic liver
segmentation my name is mustard amin i
am a research assistant and phd student
in computer vision today i am presenting
to you my course about liver
segmentation using monae and pytorch
by this course we'll start by defining
what is unit
then we will talk about how to prepare
our data
we'll start by downloading them
preparing them and doing the pre-process
then as i told you during the
pre-processing to data and applying all
the transforms that we need to do for
medical imaging using monae
then we will talk about all the
installations that we need to do from
one eye by torch cuda dnn etc etc so
we'll talk about all the packages that
we need from the python packages into
the other softwares okay
then we will talk about what are the
common problems or errors that you may
face using one eye for medical imaging
of course
then we'll talk about the training part
which which script that we will use how
does it work extra etc
then after that we will talk about the
testing parts after finishing the
training we will analyze our data not
data but we will analyze our model and
we will pass some testing
passions and see what our model is
giving us if it is going great or not
and i will give you some advices how to
fix or how to make your accuracy better
if it doesn't
go go well at the end
and after that at the end i will show
you how you can just clone the github
repository if you understand everything
i will say in this course you can just
clone the github repository and try
using the scripts so i will show you how
you can clone it how to install the
different packages and how to use all
the scripts that i am providing you in
this github repository
a little bit about unit so unite is a
deep learning architecture for semantic
segmentation it was created first for
biomedical imaging so when you if you
are interested you can read the uh
the
uh paper so in their paper you will see
that this architect architecture was
created for biomedical imaging and
because it is a great architecture and
it has a good accuracy they started
using it for the other image
segmentation tasks so now let's talk a
little bit about something else and
we'll go back to the architecture after
now maybe some of you die doesn't know
what is the difference between image
classification object detection or image
segmentation
so the image classification as you can
see it is what is the easiest task in
deep learning so image segmentation
means the image classification sorry
means that if you have an object in an
image so you just need to know if there
is no there is that specific object in
the image or not so in this case we have
a cat in the image so the output of your
model or classification model will be a
problem probability that means that you
have a cat or not with a probability
from zero to one
more closer to one means that this
object exists in the image but that's
all what you need to do this object
exists or not
then there is the object detection which
means that you need to create or to draw
a bounded box in the image or localize
the objects in the image not only saying
that this image contains a cat but you
need to draw a bonding box which means
we need to localize it in the image so
this is the object detection
then the image segmentation
means that you need to draw a mask in
the image to refer to all the pixels
that has
that have the
same
object so in our case we need to specify
which pixels
have the uh the object which is the cat
so in that in this case we need to draw
all this mask to refer to the cut in the
image so this is the image segmentation
then in the ms segmentation there are
two types that is
here the first type is the
image segmentation which is semantic
segmentation and the second one is the
instance segmentation
now here in the left you can see this is
the in semantic segmentation means that
you need only two segments how many
classes you have which means here we
have only two classes we have the class
person here and the class background so
that's all what you need to do in
instance instant segmentation you don't
care about how many people you have or
how many other objects you have in your
image you don't you don't care about
that you need only two segments
the classes that you have here we have
class person class background but in the
instance segmentation
don't only you need to create to segment
the classes but you need to specify how
many uh
objects or how many people here we have
in that image so in this case we have
person one two three
and so far which means that you need to
segment the person and say this is a
person one this is person two etc etc so
if you have two three or more than that
classes so and in each class you have
more than one object in the image so you
need to specify this is the object one
from the class x this is the
object two from the class from the same
class which is class x etc etc so unit
is an architecture to do semantic
segmentation which means it will do only
this type of segmentation it doesn't do
this type you can see faster mask
mask faster cnn to do instant
segmentation but you net you can use it
only for
semantic segmentation and that's all
what we need in our project we need to
do a
liver segmentation so we need to know
what is the liver and what is the other
part of the body which is the background
so we don't need to have there is no two
levels in the same person or something
like that so that's all what we need
segment the liver and the background so
we will for that we will use a unit here
now let's talk a little bit about the
architecture the architecture is in the
shape u for that it is called unit for
this shape okay now units you need to
know that unix is one of the easiest
architectures in deep learning there is
nothing hidden or there is nothing
difficult on it you can see that there
is only or there are only convolution
layers and followed by a max pooling
convolution layers max pooling
convolution layers max pooling and here
it will do up convolutions and max
pulling up convolutions etc but why
they are doing this because unit is
divided into two parts there is first
part called the encoder which is this
one here the down we can we can we can
call it the down blocks or the down part
here for us which is called the encoder
so we don't care about the names but
this part here is going down which is
the encoder so if you if you look
clearly to this part it is looking like
a normal image classification
architecture okay there is nothing new
that is only here
convolution blocks because this one is
called the convolution block but it is
convolution layered followed by max
pooling convolution layers max pooling
and each output of these these
convolution blocks there is a real
function so
if you understand what is happening here
you can see that this is a normal image
classification architecture
and here this is the final output that
we can put it we can pass it by a
softmax layer or something to see the
output but this is not what we need here
we said that our output that we need we
need it to be a mask with the same width
and height of the input image so that we
can specify specify each pixel
uh and its class which means pixel one
goes to class zero or class background
or class
lever or something like that for that we
need to do this part which is called the
decoder so this decoder we take the
feature that we have extracted in this
encoder part and use them here to build
the output image so that you will have
each pixel instead of having only one
pro
one probability for all the image no you
will have a probability for each pixel
so that you can classify each pixel how
many uh
uh to which class it goes for us we call
this pixel probability not a normal
image probability or something like that
now let's take an example about how does
the output of unit look like
here is for example this is one or this
is the output that i used for my project
which was the tumor segmentation in the
whole body
so i took just this example to show you
how does it look
now this is the input mask which is the
label or the ground rules you can call
it as you like so this is the input mask
i didn't have the time not time but i
didn't have the space to put the image
as well but i think this is enough to
see so this is the mask that you have
now
these are the two outputs of not it is
one output with two channels of
the unis so if you have this output here
or this output channels differs from how
many classes you have so if you have two
classes so you will have two channels
you have three classes you will have
three channels etc etc each channel will
have the pixel probability for a
specific class so in my case i had two
channels the background
two classes sorry the background class
and the foreground class which has the
tumor and in our project here we will
have two
classes the first class is the
background the second class will be the
level so this was the my outputs this is
one of my
passions
so these are
these are the channels for one output
this one refers this is the output zero
this is out this is the channel zero
this is the channel one so this one
refers to the background and this one
refers to the foreground which is the
tumor
now the values that you see here more
value more the color closer to the
yellow means that the value of these
pixels here is closer to the value one
which because we said we have pixel
probabilities which means differs from
zero to one so more we have the value
yellow more we have the uh
the
that's pixel goes to the class zero
which is the class background and more
the value goes to the purple here means
that the value is closer to zero so if
the value is closer to zero so means
that these pixels doesn't go to the
class zero which is the class background
and here same thing for this part but
this channel is the channel for the
foreground which means for the pixel 4d
for the
i forget the name this channel is for
the tumors so these
values here you can see that they are
closer to the yellow means that these
pixels
contain a
a tumor and all these pixels doesn't
contain tumor which means these pixels
are background and same thing for here
so you can use only one of these
channels to specify your your predicted
or your final prediction or you can use
all both of them and use a arg max
or you can use a softmax or anything you
want to apply or only a simple threshold
and get the final output so that's what
we will do in uh
in the
in this course so but these all these
parts will be will come later after
doing the training and etc but just i am
showing you how does the output of unit
looks like so you will have this is the
label you will have two channels or how
many classes you have in our course we
will have same thing two classes the
background and level so you will have
pixel probabilities of each color of
each pixel and using arc mugs or a
simple threshold you can specif you can
get your final binary mask which is like
this this values are one these values
are zero so this is a binary mask or
force and two you can use as anything
you want depends to
how you are uh
doing the threshold or something like
that because if you will do a normal
threshold so you have force and two if
you are using a normal arg max so you
have zero and one but it is the same
thing you don't need to care about that
now that's it and thank you for this
part and now let's do some installation
now let's talk a little bit about the
software that we need in our project we
need only two these four softwares which
are we need python vs code 3d slicer and
etg snap i am not talking about the
dependencies like python dependencies
that we need like your monae et cetera
but all these dependencies will not talk
about them now but we'll install only
the the software that we need the first
one is python as you know because we'll
execute our code using pytorch and monae
and of course using python not plus or
other programming language
then we need the
text editor where we will need to write
our code for that we need to install
vs code so this is my choice and you can
use any text editor you want but my
preference i preferably need to use
vs code but if you want or if you prefer
using another one or maybe you you want
to use jupyter notebook or something
like that it depends to you and it
doesn't change anything just i am
showing you what i will use this in this
course so you can follow me if you want
then we will use 3d slicer so this 3d
slicer we will use only to
display our data and we use it as well
for something else we may need a
conversion that cannot be done using
python but we will talk about this in
the image in the processing or in the
pre-processing part but for that we will
need this this 3d slicer software after
that we will install it snap because we
will need this type of software maybe we
will not use it in this course but maybe
you will use it because we can i will
show you how you can do the segmentation
or correct the segmentation using this
bt case now because i don't know if you
will use the same data set that i will
use or maybe you will use your custom
dataset so for that case maybe you don't
know how to segment or how to correct
your segmentation for that we'll use
this atk snap software and of course i
will show you how we can use it for now
i have all these softwares installed in
my computer but i will show you how you
can do it by your own now let's go here
we said that we need to install python
first so we have
python.org
then slash
downloads as you can see here this is
the latest version which is 3.10
if you want to use this one it's
different to you if you want to use
another version so you can just click on
windows and all these
all these
versions they are here but don't worry
about this maybe
i will show you in the following videos
when we start coding and when we start
installing dependencies we will i will
show you that sometimes we need to
create a virtual environment and where
we will install a specific version of
python in that specific virtual
environment but at first we will install
one of these versions and maybe you need
to install the 3.10 doesn't matter
because maybe we'll use it only for some
pre-process not even pre-processing but
we used for preparing the data because
we will have for we will pass by three
or four phases before doing training
because there is pre-process but before
the pre-process we need to do something
with this data because you know that
medical imaging are very very hard to
use or to treat for that we need to do
some preparation after that we'll do the
play process because these are two
different processes for that i am saying
prepare and play process because uh i am
saying i am i i want to say that there
are there are two different types okay
so if you if you want to install for
example python 3.10 just click on this
or you can just go here in downloads and
download python 3.10 and just save it
anywhere you want like this
and it will be downloaded of course
my internet connection is a little bit
slow for that i need to wait a little
bit so just you need to execute this
command and follow all these steps i
don't want to do it because i have
already python i have a lot of versions
of python installed on my pc for that i
will not do this here but you can see
that you just need to here because
in my case i have already python so i
need to install it then install it again
but for you you will have only a button
to say install and follow up all the
steps and it will be installed so i will
cancel this yes
then here we said that you need to
install python here is after that you
install it now it is done now we need to
install this text editor which is vs
code and of course i have it already as
you can see in my pc but i will show you
just how you can download it and maybe
try to install it so vs code download
like this
and you go here to code that vs code
studio and there is order is this link
both of them are official so you just
need to click here now we have windows
and it depends to how many which
operating system you have so in my case
i am using windows so you can just go
here windows and windows 10 and click on
download here or it will
start the download by itself but if it
doesn't start you can just click here on
download okay
now
you need just to install the to to
download this one maybe it will take
time because as i told you my internet
is slow these days
so just download this and install it and
follow the steps as you will do with
python and it is very easy to install as
any other software i will just cancel
here
now after
sorry after that we
don't need this for now
now
after installing this vs code
let's
talk about 3d slicer tree slicer is
the same thing it is a free software
that you can find here
3d
slicer
slicer download like this
and this is the 3d slicer download just
check which operating system you want
just take the stable
release don't take this one so just
choose windows mac os or linux and for
my case i am using windows so i need to
download and install this one but but
but as i told you i have already the
software so i will not go and install it
again especially my internet connection
is slow but you get the point download
this and install it step by step it is
free and easy
then after
installing 3d slicer here because i told
you that we will need it for some
preparation of our data and
visualization of course as well
then we have the etk snap that we will
use for segmentation by the way you can
use etk snap for
segmentation but
sorry you can use 3d slicer for
segmentation but i found this little bit
difficult because you will see that etk
snap is easy very easy it is old but it
is very easy to do the segmentation than
using 3d slicer but if you have already
used 3d slicer for segmentation so you
don't need to follow me doing this with
etk snap okay so i am telling you with
my experience i tried to use 3d slicer
and i tried to use other softwares for
segmentation but the easiest one was
atk's not for me for that i am
presenting you just need to etk snap
okay
and i cannot use use et case now for the
uh some preparation for that i need 3d
slicers so each one has a specific
advantages and disadvantages okay now
let's search for atk's not
like here we have
now
we have this or we can just click on
download
downloads here
you can see even the uh web page is too
old but it is a good software okay so
you can just choose for example windows
or and all these versions you will take
the latest one okay
now you can use for windows mac os linux
or something like that the best to you
and your operating system so for me of
course i would use this one but
i told you i have it already on my pc so
i will not take the time to download it
and install it again so that's all what
we will need for our
course i am talking about the software
we go back after to talk about the
dependencies but for now you need to
install python vs code i will leave all
the links in the description so you need
to install python vs code 3d slicer and
etk snap and aft after installing this
we'll
go back and we'll continue doing our
course
now let's talk about the data set i will
show you how you can find some public
data sets otherwise if you have already
data set in your projects then you can
use it but if you don't have and if you
maybe you are trying to do this
segmentation
just to improve your skills for that
case in this case i will show you how
you can find some public data set so the
first source that i will show you that
it was helpful for me and it contains a
lot of data
is the decathlon data set so this
digital data set
as you can see here there is
i think nine tasks we will go here that
is papers data there is more things but
what we we are
interested in is only the data set so we
just click here in the
guest data and you remember with me you
just write the card long data set you
will get the first link here but i will
leave all the links in the description
don't worry about that
but when you click here
go to get data and it will open
the google drive here and you can see
that all these tasks as there is 10
tasks as you can see here so all these
tasks means that all these are group of
data
which means it is really
you will find the volumes with the
segmentation so everything is ready just
need to download it and use it but
here you can see that there is brain
tumor there is heart there is liver as
you can see here there is hippocampus
there is pro proscad prost sorry
prostate and there are all these things
that is lung etc etc and
this one as you can see here this task
nine which is the spleen which was used
by monae
so if you go to my website here for
example i will choose it because our
course is based on moonlight as you
remember so if you go here in monae and
you see the
project that they are doing here for
example we go to
github and
most of the projects and most of the
tutorials that they are using here you
will find that they are using this
data set and we see that the because i
found this
decathlon data set from monae website so
when you go here you will find this
spleen data maybe you want to
to try it
i don't know but in our project we'll
use the liver segment the liver
segmentation so but i am not using this
one you can download this one and it
depends to you and what you want to try
okay so for me i found the data set from
cargill i will show you as well there
how you can find that and i i'm sure
that there are other data sets but for
now you can find the best ones here in
this website
and in kaggle i will show you the data
set that i will use in this project
if you go here in cargo go to datasets
maybe you you need to if you want to
search in general you can write just
healthcare images or healthcare datasets
or medical imaging and found all the
tasks that they have otherwise if you
are searching for the exact data that i
am using or i will use in this course is
lever segmentation so just write level
segmentation like this
so here you will get all these results
but these are the the because i am
saying these because there is this first
part and the second part of the data
that i used in my project in discord so
if i will open this and this in the
other another tab
you go here and you found all the these
segmentations
and these are the volume segmentations
are the labels and these are the volumes
and you can see that they are not
completed
for that there is the second part that
you will find the other volumes of the
first one here so you can download this
i have them so i will not download them
but you can download this
if you want to use the exact data that i
am using so you can download this first
part and second part put them in the
same same folder or something and we'll
go to them later
now
after that you choose your data sets
it can be this one this one or other
task but what i want you to know is
while using
monae
framework you need to have data set with
the extension nifty so
it should be and i i dot and i or
compressed nifties but you need to have
the base the base
extension nifty for that reason you need
to search for data that has nifty or or
you can search for data that can be
converted into nifty for example it can
be an ldd or an rd or it can be dcom or
any data that can be converted into
nifty otherwise you cannot use these
kinds of data with
one eye for why i am saying this because
if you are using simple 2d segmentation
you can use anything you want and you
don't need one line because i am using
monae especially for the pre-process
part because
you can't find a good framework that
help you to do pre-processing as the 3d
volumes in medical imaging
i couldn't find something better than
one eye for that i am using because mona
is great thing they are not paying me to
say this but it is a great framework for
medical imaging they have some problems
and some things that they need to fix i
will talk about them in some
in the future lectures or future minutes
but before for now i am saying that it
is great framework but
some improvements does need to be done
we will talk about them later so
i if you you need to put this in your
mind when you want to use mona you need
to have nifty files if you don't have a
specific niche device you need to find
data that can be converted into nifties
so how you can convert this data into
nifty this is another question so
some of the the some of the extensions
can be converted using python for
example like the dcom images if you have
series of decode because a nifty file is
a series of decomps because the decom
here i will show you an example
this one as you can see here this is all
these decons that's that goes to one
passion so all these d comes each d com
is one slice of a ct scan when we
combine them all these d comes together
we get one volume that one volume is one
nifty file because when you take one
nifty file and put it into the slicer or
any other software to visualize it you
will see that it it contains a lot of
slices so each slice is a decom file
that's what you need to know i don't
know if you know that but i am just
saying that
so
as i studio try to find nifty files or
files that can be converted into nifties
now you get this data if you want to
convert them for example if you want to
if you have dcoms like these and you
want to convert them into nifty you can
use 3d slicer but i think that for this
kind because there is a
python uh
the patent package that
does help you to do this conversion for
that we don't need to use this there is
d come to a nifty package that you can
use it install it using pip install but
don't worry about it we will do this
later because now i am just talking in
theory but we will do the code to do
this conversion after for now i am just
telling you that you can do this
conversion using tv slicer but i don't
recommend you because it will take time
to upload or to load the data and save
it so don't think about this for now
but if you have for example nld images
or something like that for that case
maybe you cannot convert them using
python for that you need to pass by this
software here
now let me tell you something
how you can convert data using this i i
will just show you how i i did that so
what you can do because i had a problem
when i was doing some segmentations i
couldn't save them as nifties so i had
segmentation or labels they were in
energy extension for us i needed to
convert them into uh
into the nifty for that i passed by this
software
so now let's take for example this is a
nifty file we don't need to convert it
but just to show you how you can do that
imagine with me this is an nrd file to
open it just
pass it and put it here in the in your
software and drag and drop it in the
software and click ok and it will be
opened as a volume here and if i will
scroll with the mouse you can see here i
am passing by all the cuts or all the
slides which are already decompiled okay
so that's what i was talking about when
i am scrolling this here i am passing by
all the decon files that have been
combined to create one nifty file now
imagine with me this was a nrd file for
example now i want to convert it into an
ec what you can do just put it here drag
it and drag it and drop it here it will
be opened or you can just open it here
file open etc
now to convert it click on save
now just
don't take this one and check your file
here you need to see because this one is
the project you don't need to uh
to save it so just save your file here
if you have multiple files you can drag
them all together here and they will you
wish you they will show you all the
files here that you have been opened and
you
with one click you convert them all at
the same time okay so here let's say
that this was a nrd file
so here you can see that there is the
there are all these
kinds of files and led like this one for
example if imagine with me our file was
energy now you want to easy to
save it as a nifty file so just click
here search for nifty it will be here so
there is this one nifty this one the
same thing but this one is complete
compressed i recommend you to use
compressed so that you will save some of
your memory you don't need to worry
about
compressed files when you use monai
because it will know how to i will show
you how to do that because you don't
need to worry about that so i recommend
you to save them as nifty which means
nii dot gz which is compressed so click
here
and click on save or you can choose the
directory when you where you want to
save your file then click on save and it
will save your file if you have multiple
files
just change them all here in the place
of nld puts
nifty and change them all and click on
save it will save them all together in
the same
repository that you want so that was how
to convert
any file i am not saying any but you
need to see here you have there is nld
meter image all this kind of files so if
you have data set with this extensions
and for that and you want to use monae
so you need to convert them into nifties
so you need to pass them by this
software for example and change them
maybe
maybe you have some extension that
doesn't exist here so you need to search
another software or maybe there is a
python script that does that
so that's my recommendation but if you
find directly nifty files of or if you
will use directly the data set that i
used here like this one and this one
in this case you don't need to convert
anything because they are already
nifty's okay
so that was about the data set and in
the next uh
in the next lecture on next minute we'll
start doing some pre-process to our data
and there is something we need to talk
about before doing the pre-process but
don't worry we'll go step by step until
the end of this project
now let's start preparing our data as i
told you in the last parts of this
course i said that there are two
different parts there is the preparation
of the data and there is the pre-process
i am calling them this because there is
the preparation that we will do manually
and it will we will do it in another
with
script without doing the pre-process
because the pre-process we need to do it
directly before the training so
before doing that we need to clean the
data because
medical imaging are a little bit
confused we can't use them directly to
our model or our segmentation or
anything like that because if we use
them directly we will have some problems
and will not have good accuracy and even
we cannot fix our problem and we cannot
even know where is the problem there so
for that reason we need to do some
preparation to our data before starting
the pre-process or the training or
anything uh that we will do later on
so
as i told you there is the data here in
the catalog data set and there is in
kaggle
let's go here and and i will show you
that we will use this
this card this decathlon data set i i
have already downloaded prepare it and
everything i have done but i will show
you only with two or three passes to
show you how does it
work and
so that you will have an idea how to
pre-process your own data okay
because if i will do the pre-process or
the preparation of all the data
it will take time but we don't need that
because when you understand how to do it
for one or two passions you can do it
for all the buttons and don't worry
about the code i will provide you
everything
uh that will use here in this tutorials
so don't worry about that now as i told
you you can you go you go here to get
data and it will open this one and as i
showed you we are doing lever
segmentation so this is the details that
you need to download as you can do just
like this click with your right
right hand and click here in download
and it will be downloaded and you can
use it directly okay
now after that you will download this
data it will look like something like
this
and after that you decompress it it will
be something like this and when you
enter you will find all these files we
don't need them you can do it delete
them but you will find three different
folders this one is image tier which
means image images for the training and
this one are images for the testing and
this last one is labels for the training
which means you can see that there are
labels only for the training images
there is no labels for the testing
images so in that
in this case it is easy to understand
what is delivered but in some cases it
is not easy but for now we will not in
this course will not need
this training you can leave it here but
we will not need it because at the end
of our training we need a label so that
we can compare the label with the images
that we have with the output that our
model will predict so in this case we'll
take only the images training images and
testing and training labels and we'll
take few passions from
from the training maybe we'll take 10 or
20 because we have here you will find
that you have 130 these are only because
it is
redo it here after the completion but in
reality there are only 130 passing so if
you take 10 or 30 passes for the
validation or for the testing so
not all of the because validation is
different than testing so because in our
case we do training and testing will not
do validation because when you go to
monae
tutorials you will find that they are
using the word validation validation but
i am not sure that this was the
validation because
because it is true that they will use
that data during the training but it is
not validation because they will not
affect the training or the model they
used only to calculate metrics and to uh
to yes to test their
model for that case we cannot call them
validation they are testing data set not
validation for that because actually we
will not we will use almost the same
code
i am talking about the preprocess and
the training we use almost the same code
provided by monae but we will do some
changes for example i will not use the
word validation i will use testing etc
etc but we will go to this uh real back
to do this to go to this later but now
as i do you will when you will download
the data you will find or you will find
all these passions but as i told you i
will not do the process for all the
passes because it will take time and
memory and i have already this data so
what i did i just took two end here of
course the the images with the
labels so what you need to do is just to
uh
follow me how i will do this uh process
for two patients and after that i will
show you how you can do it for more uh
you will know how to do it for all your
passions but there is something that i
need to talk to tell you about is here
in monae you will see that they are
using something because when you want to
train your data or your uh images here
in
medical imaging there are two ways to do
it because we have images with 512
by 512 i am talking about the width and
the height and the number of slices in
different difference sometimes you will
find 20 sometimes you will find 50
sometimes you will find 500 it differs
from it differs from your uh
task and your data set okay
so in that case we cannot use directly
the data because we need to create the
same
dimensions of each input so that will
not get the model confused so when we
will fix the width and height for five
and five twelve by five twelve
and for example slices by 100 so we we
need to get all the pacings or all the
inputs with this same
dimensions for that when you see in
monae's tutorials you will find that
they are doing some crops so that they
can get the same dimensions but that
method work for some cases but it
doesn't work for others
and i tested that method in this lever
segmentation it and it doesn't give a
good result okay for those i will not
use it but i will show you just a little
bit explain to you how they are using
that and why i will not you use it and
how can we prepare our data to to use my
my way it is not my way but what i found
better than the more nice way
so the method used by monae or monitors
they take for example this is a passion
i am showing you only one slice but
imagine with me you have a number of
slices here which is a volume which is
actually a nifty file so what they do
they do they create some crops
they create random crops but i am
showing you like this so that you will
understand but they are doing random
crops here for example a crop here or in
the crop here which means they create a
window with defined width and height and
number of slices and they take this crop
the the that they used they cropped
using that window and they pass it for
the training and the same thing they
take in but
they do they take one crop for one uh
one epoch then in the next epoch they
take another crop like this and the
other one another couple from and they
are random crops not as i am showing you
here but just to know how does it look
so that that's what they are doing in
their tutorials they take only small
crops and do the training on this crop
and describe this crop etc etc for that
they use 600 epochs so that they can
pass by all almost all the passenger or
almost all the slices but
i tested this way but it doesn't work
well for me for that i want to show you
how i will do i will do it in my way
which means we will create by ourselves
uh
this window but what i what we will do
we will let the width and the height the
same or we can resize the image but we
will not crop it like this or so we will
not take only small parts from the image
but we will take the whole
as you can see the whole shape or the
whole content of the image maybe yes not
maybe but we will
resize the images because if we want to
apply to pass them 512 by 512 to the
model it will take forever to be trained
for that we need to resize the images
and what we can do maybe we can crop
this areas so that we take only the
places or only the area that has content
of the image but otherwise we not need
to take uh small portions as monai are
doing so what i would recommend you i
recommend you to not i am recommending
you or i will show you how how i will do
this on my way how to create the small
uh passions or the small slices groups
of slices and
if you like it or if you want to try it
out i will show you everything that you
do all the scripts that we will use etc
etc otherwise if you want to use the
moniz tutorial like that so maybe you
can follow me just to understand some of
the basics and some of the functions
that what i provide but in this way you
can you want you will not use my
idea and you can skip maybe one hour or
something like that from this video
because i will be explaining everything
to do to prepare the data because if you
will use this way you don't need to do
any preparation maybe there is a process
to change the contrast etc but
preparation which means cleaning how
many slices you have how how many groups
you have you don't need to do all that
but if you want to follow me so you need
to see how i am doing this and after
finishing the course you can try this
one and maybe you can try
more nice tutorial or more nice way in
your data maybe the other way will work
for you well because
it doesn't work for me maybe it works
for you okay so let's now let's go to
show you what are the preparations we
will need and how to do them
so the method that i am proposing is to
create small groups which means we will
leave the same width and height for now
before the pay process will leave the
same width and height of all the slides
of all the passions but we will create a
constant number of slices which means if
we have for example a passage with 120
slices what we will do for example we
will create if we will
if we will make a constant number of
slices for example like 60 60 slices per
group so what does it mean dispassion of
120 of 120
slices we will divide it into two groups
so it will be the passion zero for
example uh slash one for example this is
the first part so it will be
with 60 slices and the next part will be
with another 60 slices and the same
thing for all the passions if we fix the
number as 60 slices per group or per
input that means that we will pass by
all passions and divide them into groups
of 60 slices this is the idea that i
found because maybe you can if you
because i don't know how
what is your data that you are using
because if for example you have
passenger with almost almost the same
number of slices for example 100 101 102
or and something like this and all these
passions have almost this range of
slices in this case you may not need to
do what i will do here because you may
you can do in the training you can crop
your passions and fix the number of
slices into 100 slices per input which
means if you have a passion with 150 100
slice so this passion will go directly
as an input or if you have a passion
with 100 one and one slices means that
you will crop only one slice and one
slice it doesn't affect your uh
your data because for example if you
crop your data and maybe you you will
clear or
10 or 20 slices this maybe you will lose
some information of your passion but if
you just take off only one slice or two
slices it doesn't affect your training
or your data i hope that you are
understanding what i am saying because
if you have only you have almost all
this the passion to have almost the same
number of slices so in this case you
don't need any
preparation of this asians but if you
have a random data set that has passion
with 50 slices another passing with 500
another percent with 300 something like
that because all the passing that you
will all the data that you will find as
public data sets you will find them like
that so if you will find out like that
you need to follow me to clean them and
make them ready for the training so the
first thing that you need to do is to
convert these nifty files into dcoms so
that you can convert or you can create
small groups okay
to do that for now there is no specific
python package to do this because i
searched for that i didn't find i i
tried to create my own package to do
this and you will find it on my
github profile here
like you will find i mean zero one one
zero slash nifty to dcom so that was i
tried to create and you will find it
here it is useful for some cases but not
for this case because there is a problem
that i couldn't find how to fix it and
if any one of you have a suggestion
please you can leave it in the comment
or you can just take the code and make
it ready for you i will tell you what is
the problem with this code and so that
you will understand
this code will create will take a nifty
file and create your decon slices but
the problem here is that it will give
all the slices or all the decomp slices
the same number of index what does it
mean if you have a nifty file with 10
for example 10 slices so when you will
convert it into deconfile it decompiles
it should be each num each slice or each
deconfile with
with different index so for example the
first nifty file will be with the index
0 the second one with the index 1 2 3
until 10 which means if you want to
reconstruct or rebuild the nifty file
after
the
python package will understand that this
first slice is goes to the first nifty
uh
to the first
[Music]
item of the nifty the second one is the
second cut third etc etc but the code
that i i'm providing here will give the
same index to all the passions which
means not the passing to all the slices
so if you convert one nifty file into
ten sli nifty into 10 decom slices all
these dcom slices will have the index 0
for example yes the first index so in
that case you cannot rebuild the nifty
file again so
in our case we need to rebuild because
we need to take groups of d columns and
reconvert them into the two nifty files
which means it doesn't work for us maybe
this type of convergence if you need
only to convert into dcom you don't need
to
or you don't need the indexes in that in
that case you can use this but otherwise
for our project we cannot use this even
if maybe if you find a way how to change
the indexes so you can take the code and
change the indexes of all the deconfiles
otherwise i will show you how you can do
it manually without without python code
for that this this is the parts that
take a lot of time of this work but the
others are just coding and everything
will i will provide you all the scripts
for everything but only this part needs
to be done manually and it will take
time sorry about that but it will take
time for that i am saying if any one of
you know how to convert nifty to dcom
using python or something like that
please provide this in the comments so
that anyone
who is using doing these projects can
use this package
as well okay thank you for now
now
i will show you the second way that you
can do it but as i told you it will take
time
we will use 3d slicer for that when we
was installing softwares i told you that
we'll use 3d slicer for for some
conversions so now it is the time to
talk about that
i will show you how you can do one or
two
not i have i i just choose two buttons
here so i will show you these two passes
how you can
convert the images and the labels and
you can do this you can see that it is
easy but it
takes time so you can do it for all the
passings that you have so now let's
start by before that i want just to
create some folders
so that we can know where to put our
data because i didn't want to make
everything with python script because
sometimes it is very you can pass
10 minutes writing a script to do
something so that you can say that it is
automatically but you can create the
folder with one in one minute so just
click new and create a folder so it will
take
two or three seconds but if you want to
write python script it will take maybe
three minutes or more than that so in
that case i prefer to do it manually
instead of writing a python code to do
it okay
now let's call it for example dcom
decom files maybe because what we will
do in this folder we will take these
passions and convert each of them into
the com slices because nifty is group of
dcoms now let's go here this is the
decom which creates another folder here
one for the images i will call it for
example images
and then the other one we will call it
the if you want to do it directly with
the keyboard you can just click ctrl
shift and end which is new so we will
create a new folder here so this next
one we call it labels something like
that this
this files or these folder names will be
changed after because we need them for
our specific script but don't worry
about that we
will come to that later now we have two
folders this one images and this one
labels
now let's do what i was saying to use
this software 3d slicer let's start by
the images let's take the first one just
grab it here drag and drop into your
slicer or just you can open it here
and now okay open it
and it will be opened here as you can
see all these the slices you can just
scroll down or just do like this so all
these are the slices for example this
passion has
you can just you can read here you can
see here it is
74 slices and you can go to other
passions you will find maybe 100 slice
etc etc so this is the problem you
cannot use the same script for all the
passengers for that we need to prepare
them with the same slices after that we
pass them by the to the training phase
okay now how to convert them just click
here
insert and
click or type here dcom
creates the ad com series so search for
create a dcom city so just go here
in search
dcom
creates the comp series so when you
click here click two times here you will
get this window here the first thing
that you need to do is there is nothing
uh is hard to do it this is you don't
need to change this because creating it
becomes serious so you don't need to
change that
click here on select you need to select
the volume or yes the volume or the
image that you want to
to convert so here you can see that we
have volume zero this is the the
passing that we are displaying now and
this is the passing that we want to
convert so you know you need just to
choose it here
level zero now
you need to
choose or to change the directory where
you want to be to put your conversion
now as we were saying we need to go to
here to our folder that we have created
called nifty files
go here
youtube
yes
this one dataset
lever and deconfiles
and this one is an image not a label or
segmentation so we go to the image now
we need to create a folder for because
if we passed here everything will be
here every every slice or all the decon
files will be here but we need to to put
them into one in one folder which is
called with the same name of this button
so we need to create a folder here so we
can call it lever 0 for example
and with the same thing or you if you
want to change the name here it doesn't
matter
now choose now everything is set just
click here in apply
and you will see that it had the
conversion have been completed let's go
here and see what's happened here images
we have created this and here are all
slices as you can see we have 75 from 0
from 1 into 75 so everything everything
is set and these are all the slices
because here we see that the maximum is
74 because it starts from the index 0 so
from 0 to 75 but here
it is starting from 1 into 75
okay so there is no problem with that
but these are all the slices for this is
for the image one for the lever one now
let's do it for the second
just go here
and
the second here we have we had image
which is level one
now
level zero now level one
open it here and you can see now we have
the lever one and for example this one
this one have 122
slices which you can see it is not as
the first one for that case it was it
will pose a big problem when you want to
do it or you will lose all the
information of your passing if you do
some crops for that we need to create
groups with the same number of slices
now let's select the second one which is
what we uploaded now this one level one
and here we need to change the path
because we had the folder level zero now
we need level one something like that
and that's it choose
and apply
this
so now we have the two passengers have
been the have been
converted here
let's go images this is the second one
now let's do the same thing with the
labels let's go here we have label
training let's take the first one here
and as you can see this is labels with
the same number of slices now let's
select here you can see because they had
the same
name level zero level zero so they added
this index so that you can know so this
is the first this is the first label
for for the first passing as well now
we will not do it in images now we are
in labels so create a new folder call it
here lever
you need to put it the same because we
choose we choose to put the lever zero
so we need to put the same thing lever
and zero so another so that's the uh
when we will do the training etc
the the labels with their images will be
the same okay
now let's choose this one
yes
here we have the same thing choose and
apply
and the same thing for the second one
which is lever one
choose it here
change to
level then one
and choose it apply
and now everything is set for this step
when we go here
the confines you will find images
here is for the first one second one and
same thing for the labels this is the
first one and the second one as well
so that's what you need to do at first
but for me i am showing you only two
passions but you you need to do all the
passing sorry it will take time but i
didn't find another way to do that okay
so as i told you if you have the number
of slices sorry i am repeating the word
but just to understand if you have if
you have the same number of slices for
all the passions or almost the same with
a minus one or one difference between
them so in this case you don't need to
do what i am doing here but if you have
the public data set as i am saying here
as you see
you i show you the first if i show you
only two passes the first one has 74 the
second one have
uh 122. so in that case you can see that
there is a difference so if we go or if
you pass by all the passengers we will
see that every passing has each
its is
unique if we can say unique number of
slices which is a problem for that we
need to pass by this way now after doing
this what we have to do we need to
create the groups that i was talking
about groups of decom slices which is we
can choose any number we want
in this case i will choose 64. i don't
know why i choose this white but this
number
maybe i found that the minimum of
because i passed by all the passions
maybe i found that the
person that has less slices was between
maybe 64 or 65 for that i choose that
number but for you it depends to you and
you need to choose
the number of slices that you want or
that is depending to your data set
so you can do the same thing as i did
you go by the the passes that you have
you see the but the passing that has
less number of slices and you take those
numbers so that you will not lose that
passion because if you take number more
than
the minimum which means that you will
lose that dispassion if you choose for
example
number of slices unique number slices
equal 100 and you have some passion that
are having number of slices 60 for
example so 60 past ends 60 slices can
not be converted into 100 slides so you
will lose this passion for that for this
case i am telling you to see the person
that has the less number of slices and
take that number of slices as a
reference or a constant number for all
the other passions okay
now for the next steps which is doing
all the conversion creating the groups
and reconverts into uh
nifty files everything will do it using
python so i will show you how you can do
it but before talking about or before
starting coding i am just telling you
that everything is set for now all the
code all the scripts all the functions
are here in github which i will share
with you after you can find everything
here the preprocess and everything is
here but we will write this code
each line by code
by ourself but after that i will provide
you everything here and i will provide
you the notebook jupyter notebook maybe
you need you you you would like to use
it because in our case we will use
jupyter notebook in some cases because
it is easier to follow the steps but you
will find everything here in github
which you will find the link in the
description
so now let's start creating the groups
and converting them into nifties
now as i was telling you that you can
use jupiter notebook that i i will show
you how you can use it i am sure that
you know how to use it but maybe
did you use it in different way that's
what i want to say because you can
install it easily in the command window
like you go here in cmd you can open
this command window just type pip
install then jupyter
and it will be installed and you can
open it uses and there is no problem
with that but the problem that you can
you may have using this uh jupiter
notebook directly here is not probably
in the installation but
if you want to use a virtual environment
in your in your project in that case it
is sometimes it is not easy to
open or to
yes to open jupiter notes book inside a
virtual environment or to use gyptonium
with virtual environments
so
the way that i recommend you because i
always choose the easiest way and i will
show you the easiest way
if you like it you can use it otherwise
you can use something else but as i told
the jupiter notes book if you install it
like this there is no problem but when
you want to use it with a virtual
environment you will have some problems
so to make it easy to do this process
what you need to do is just to go
install anaconda navigator
so anaconda navigator is as you can see
it is a software that has multiple i
will show you multiple software here
that you can use and which is the is
which is the best thing here that you
can create your virtual environments
with using conda not a virtual
environment with python because there is
python vms which is python vertical
environment and there is conda virtual
environment and when you use anaconda
you can create your contact but your
environment you can create them using
command windows like this here click
here contact install and or contact
create you and you create your virtual
environment exactly with a specific
python version and all these things that
you want to set
but if you are beginner with programming
maybe
it will be easy to create your virtual
environment manually using the gui here
anaconda gui so
to do that you just come here i will
show you first how to down install it
which is very easy you can just go here
to anaconda dot com slash product slash
individual i will leave the the
link in the description don't worry
about that so when you install your
anaconda here and you you download it
here and you you follow all the steps as
we have installed everything else
because i have it already so that i
cannot install it reinstall it again but
just download it because it is free
download this open it and it will and
follow the steps and of course you need
to choose which operating system for me
i am using windows so it is already
windows here if you have mac or
something else so just you need to click
here and search for your operating
system
now after installing it just open it as
here you can when you start it will be
something like this now
here if you open here this list you will
you will see all the uh virtual
environment that you have in your pc
that you have created in your pc they
will be shown here and this is the
base when you will create or you will
install an account you will find only
these two uh vertical environment this
is the base which is the base vertical
environment of your pc this one mini
contact is we can say that it's an
example but you will not need it because
we will install our virtual environment
for our project this is testing i just
installed it again
but
now how to create a virtual environment
in anaconda as actually you can do it
using the command window here cmd and
you can create use the command line and
install and create a virtual environment
then activate it etc
but the easiest way here while we are
using the since we are using the gui
already you can go here environments and
you can see as i show you all the
environment that you have here now to
create new virtual environments that is
here these buttons create a new cloud
import backup remove if you want to
remove one of these various environments
so as we said we want to create one so
click on create
now choose the name of your virtual
environment let's call it for example
liver segmentation so this virtual
environment will be the virtual
environment that we will use in our
projects and i will talk about this
after but now when you use it check here
in python then here you can choose any
any python version that has been
installed in your pc
and just for me i have python 2.7 3.5.6
i have everything here so i will just
choose 3.8 you can choose any version
you want but i am going to choose 3.8
and i recommend you to do this because
sometimes when using mulai if you go
with latest versions maybe you will find
some problems so
three point seven three point eight is
enough for this project so i will choose
three point i ate then here create
and you will see that the vertical will
be created in
millisecond not millisecond but in
a few seconds and now we just have to
wait
and this is our virtual environment and
now here you can see the uh files or the
packages or libraries that have been
installed already with the virtual
environment as you can see we have pip
we have python of course sqlite etcetera
but we will not use these because we
need other packages like numpy money etc
but everything we need to install it by
ourselves so the installed packages
there is multiple ways to do it we can
use conta install we can use pip install
or we can just can come here we have
here when we are checking here only we
are seeing only installed packages we if
we click here not installed updatable
etc or we can click just in all we will
get all the python
packages that have been
that are available in anaconda and
search for anything here then click
install but i when we are talking about
installing packages i don't prefer this
way i prefer using pip for that i will
not follow this way i will show you how
we can use pip
to install different packages
so now what we need
click create a virtual environment now
when you are selecting it here means
that you are activating because if you
have already used virtual environments
it can be virtually environmental python
virtual environment or a more conda
inverting environment when you did it
you have always to create it then
activate it when you write virtual
environments like script slash activate
or source virtual slash bin slash
activate
but
when you use the gy here when you select
it here means that it is activated you
don't need to do something else to
activate your virtual environment
now
as i was saying we really need to use
jupiter notebook so here as you can see
there is jupyter notebook there is
everything vs code there is pycharm
there is everything here we can install
it we will install this because we need
this after but for now what we need is
just to use jupyter notebook so you
click here even if you didn't install it
before in your life don't worry about it
it will be installed when you click here
it will be installed in your virtual
environment which means that you can use
it there
so now let's create let's click in
install and it will install
jupyter notebook in this virtual
environment
now it is installed as you can see and
this is the best thing when using
anaconda navigator because you don't
need to think about how to uh
to link the your
virtual environment with jupiter
notebook or sunday lines you don't need
to care about that
the only thing that you need to do is
select or create a virtual environment
selected then come here and now it is
already installed so you will not you
don't need to install it every time now
you installed if only one time in your
new virtual environment now click in
launch it will be launched and we will
say
here
now there is jupyter notes book is
working and now jupyter notebook is open
with your or inside your virtual
environment so you don't need to think
or care about which virtual environment
you have or anything else now all what
you need to do is to create your folder
to check or to make directory where you
want to put your your stuff on your
project and inside that folder you
create a new notebook now for me i
selected this so i will work on this
repository which is labor segmentation
here where we will put everything or all
the code
not the data data is somewhere else but
here we will put only the code now
to create a new notebook just come here
click on new as you can see there is
python 3 that is text file folder
terminal but for us we want to create
jupyter notebook for python so python 3
ipi ipu
sorry iby kernel so ipwa i ipu y means
that jupiter notebook and kernel
now
uh what we will do here we have this is
our notebook just you can click here to
rename it i will give it for for example
prepare because we will use this
notebook for now to do the preparation
because we were talking
now a few few minutes ago we saw we said
that we need to convert our images here
we had this labels and images they are
decode now we need to create groups or
yes create groups with the number of
slices then reconvert these groups into
into nifty files so that's what we will
do in this
notebook now to do the creation of the
groups of
64 slices this was my choice if you want
something else you can change it
now these are my two parts this is the
inputs and this is the output path the
output parts we need to talk about it
here
i have i have because we had this dcom
files where we have we had images and
labels this is the input path file decon
files and we have images and labels
we'll start by labels for example then
the output part i have created this
folder called dcom groups so you need to
create a folder you can call it anything
you want so that we will take this
labels from this
that we will convert or because we will
not convert actually sorry we will
create
groups of 64 slices so what will happen
now we will create
each for each group will create a folder
but we will not do it manually all what
we need to do is create this group where
we will save all the passions all the
groups which i call decom groups but we
will write the script that will create
folder for each group which is 64 slices
so that we can
after that we can convert this 64 slice
into one nifty file but before that what
we need to do is to create this decon
groups which will be a
which will be a folder now there is
something else that we need to talk
about because we have this decon groups
but what we need to do we need to create
another folder one for the labels one
for the images i am sorry i know that i
am doing a lot of things manually but i
didn't want to do everything using
python scripts because in sometimes you
can do something wrong and everything
went wrong because imagine with me if
you mix only one
one person which i mean if you ma you
may you put wrong a one
label means that everything will go
wrong because in segmentation you need
to be very precise it is not like any
other thing
it's not like any other task of computer
vision so you need to be precise because
if you skip only one slice or only one
segmentation everything may be wrong
okay for that i am doing much things uh
manually so that i
i will not make
these things wrong there are some stuff
that need to be using not need to be
done using python scripts but for this i
prefer to do it manually now as i told
you i need to create a group a folder
for labels i add another folder for the
images so we just click here as i told
you ctrl shift and n for new folder i
will call it labels the first one and
the second one for the images like this
so now here i need to add
labels
okay so the input path is our labels
when we have because for me i am using
only two passings as i told you but you
for you you have all the passings in
your labels because here the confines i
have only two passions but for you you
have 130 if you use the same dataset or
i don't know but you have all the labels
that you have here and the output path
is what we have created now beacon
groups and labels now here where we will
save our our
groups of decons
now to do this just run this one so to
run it just click you can click in run
or you can click on shift enter shift
enter it will
run this cell
now
to do this project we need to install
some not projects but i am talking only
about this part we will need some
packages so the first one is globe so
this package globe if you have already
used it so you don't need to know what i
am saying but if you haven't used before
so we need is only to create some parts
or to restore all the parts for example
here i have this
folder
which has two passions so the globe
function or the globe library will help
us to
restore the
the whole link or the whole part so that
we can open this folder and open this
folder after you will understand when we
will code it okay now i haven't
installed it for this project so we need
to install it to install in if you are
using directly visual code or you are
trying to install in a
terminal just you need to click to
put pip install
then the name of the package for us it
is glo but for me if you are using
jupyter notebook so you need to add this
mark okay because if you don't add it it
will not work in jupyter notebook now if
i will run this cell
it will install there is something wrong
could
[Music]
sometimes you can get something wrong we
need to see about this why it is not
installing
now after that i checked because i don't
know why i didn't notice that but when
you want to install globe sorry about
that but we need to check everything
every time
because i have installed this a long
time ago for that i don't remember i
didn't remember that i need to add this
number two with the globe but that's
that's what we need to do because this
type of uh
errors means there it is true that they
are saying no matching distribution
found for globe but what they are saying
that there is nothing
because they don't write that but there
is there is no something like this
library because the same thing if i i
can put pip install i don't know one two
three it will say it will give the same
error it will not say that there is
nothing called one two three but it will
say that we couldn't find something
matching with this version but that
means that you are
putting the name of the package wrong so
you need to just choose because
sometimes you can see the globe when you
import it you just put import
globe but when you install it there is
something else all not all the packages
but a lot of packages have this no
problem but
you need to see exactly
what is the name that you need to use
when you want to install for example
pillow when you install it you click pip
install pillow but when you import it
you click just pip install pil so for
that this is the same thing just click
here pip install globe 2 then run it
and now as you can see it is installed
now there is no problem now the second
package that we need to install is
chantel
shuttered sorry not chanted but because
we need this package to move the
files because what we will do we will
move some
lot some but we move 64 past 64 slices
to a new folder which is a group of 64
slices because i didn't want to just
copy them because we will lose a lot of
memory doing this copy and paste but i
will move them so i will take them from
the old
directory and post them and put them
into the new directory so for that we
will use we need this
library so pip install
shuttle i hope that you need to use the
same name maybe there is something else
but we will see as you can see the same
thing here so what we need to do is just
to
search for it
how to install
shuttle something like this
and as you can see
when you import it you use shuttle but
when you want to install it there is by
test shuttle so you cannot just install
it as i was doing so just take the name
and put it here
pip install test shuttle now let's see
how does it work
it will take a few seconds and
now everything is good so i will just
delete this so to delete them just click
on the cell and click two times on d to
delete and the same thing for this
because i we have already installed them
so we don't need them there now we need
to import them so import
globe and import
shut d
like this
but but what you need to do to know is
in globe function
this is the name of the package which is
globe but the function that we need has
the same name which is globe so for that
when we want to use the globe we cannot
just make glo use globe and deer
function we need to import another
function or another class called globe
from globe
that we will use i know that it is
strange but that's it this is the
package they created like this
so we need to write from globe
import globe
because the same class are the same in
the same package so that's what we need
because if you take just globe you
cannot access to the packages or to the
functions that we will need so just run
this now there is no problem with that
now let's start coding or let's start
creating the groups for that the first
thing that we have to do is to create a
good not a good but a big for loop
because that for loop is the most thing
that because
what we are saying we are we want to
pass by all the passions because we
can't do it for only one person but we
need to run the code each time for 130
passes which is not good so we need to
create a loop that passes by all the
passions so for that we need to create
just four
and now passion which is a lever for for
me i have two only two passes but for
you you have everything but you don't
need to care about that just for passing
and we will use the path because you
remember in the part here we have labels
after that we'll use the images so in
labels there are all the uh
all the decon files that you have
converted for now
so what we have to do for passions in
then here what we are saying in this
folder but
if we do this we will not have
the
because this in
in part will be only one part but what
we have to do we need a list of parts
okay list of parts each part or each
item of this list give us the part to
one passion okay for that we need to use
the globe this is the use of globe
function so we have globe and when we
put a part inside this parenthesis of
the globe function what it will do it
will return a list of
all
the items that it has in there in the
directory not the list like os.list
because here we are talking about lists
of the parts not only the items so this
is the role of globe function so what we
have to do is in path
input path
but
when you want to do this you need to
specify which extension or which type of
folders you want to put in this list so
for that we need to add something like
because always we have
something or the name of the file that's
the extension for example and i for the
nifty but for us we don't have nifties
but we have folders
okay for that we don't need to specify
the extension just put everything okay
but this is something like this so what
we are saying that in this input part
slash everything
if we want to say
uh
we want to specify the extension so we
have to put everything that some that's
the
nifty for example this what does it mean
everything which is we don't care about
the names all the names or all the files
that have the extension and ii take them
but for us we said that we have folders
so we need to take everything inside
this folder so for passing globe in
star means that everything inside that
folder
so this will return a list of
folders now what we have to do is to
start doing the conversion the first
thing that i want to do is to return the
patient's name so that we will use it
after to save or to create a new folder
for
for each group of items because what we
have what we will have for example we
have a passion with 128
slices so this passage will be divided
into two groups the first group is 64.
the second one is 64. so what we have to
do we want to keep the same name of
passing for example pass into one in our
case we have lever zero lever one so we
will keep the same name level zero but
we need to add a underscore for example
than one
and two three etc which is the sub
groups so you have the passion zero
sl underscore one
lever
then passion one underscore two
that pass into i don't know passing two
underscore one etcetera etcetera
etcetera so you will know always that
this group of 64 belongs to this to the
passions one or passing two etc but it
is a subgroup of that passion okay i
know that i am talking a lot but i am
just trying to explain everything here
so as i told you i need to return the
name of that passages before that we
have to add a
another library that we'll use so import
os
and you should know that in each time
you add something in that cell you need
to run it again because if we don't run
it this os will not be imported okay so
now
after that we did this what we have to
do we have to return the passion's name
so i will call it for example passion's
name
so as we said this loop will take the
first passion will return its name to
return its name that is a function in
the os library so os
dot path
dot
base name
okay this one will return the base name
which is the name of uh
of our passions which when we say this
base name means that we have all this
part this is the base name
the last item of the path is the base
name and that's what we need because now
we have label so this globe will do
slash than the first passion so when we
return the first uh i will show you
something
let me just click here below
now let me do for example past scenes
list
equal
glow
then in path
plus
this so this as we said this is the uh
this list of passions will have for us
we have only two persons so now if i
will i want to print for example print
the first item of the list which should
be the path to the first passion so we
have passing list
then as we said the first item of the
list so zero the index zero now you can
see that we will have
the input path here
plus the lever which is the first
passion so that's what i was saying if i
will put here one
it will give us the lever one which is
the second passing etc etc now we don't
need this so i will delete it
now i understand what will be this
passing in the first iteration i i
forget here in
so
you know that now in the first iteration
we will have the first passing which is
the part of the passing so labor slash
level zero
so what we will do we return that level
zero the only the name which will be a
string we will use it after
for that what we have to do
now
inside the parenthesis we need to know
to normalize our path in case we have
any problem or something like this so os
dot
path
dot norm
path which is normalizing the path and
put here the name of the passing which
is this one or not the name but the
parts of the passions so this function
will normalize the path if and there is
anything wrong with that
then this function will return the name
or the last item of the path which will
be the name of the passage and it will
be here we will need it after to create
a folder and to save the groups in our
case
now
after doing this what we have to do we
need to specify or to know how many
folders we have
or how many groups we will divide our
passions so if we have for percent with
160 28 for example slice it will be
divided into two so we need to create
two folders each folder for us for
number of four the first 64 and second
one same thing if we have more than that
we have to create more than that more
folders etc etc so before we need to to
know how many folders we need for this
for this first passage for example so to
do this we have just create
number of folders
folders then what we need to do is to
ins
because why i am putting is because we
need an integral number because if you
have for example 130 you divide it by
64. it will be a float number but we
cannot create a fluid float number of
folders we need to an integral so we
need to put everything inside the
function int so that it will convert the
final division into a in
into an integer okay
now what we have to do we have the
because what we need to do we have a
globe of the passing that we have which
is this one
this one is the globe of the passion
this will return how many passions we
have but now we need to know how many
slices we have in that specific passion
so we need to create another globe which
will be something like this globe but
now we are not talking about the in
the in part which is the input path now
we are talking about the patch of that
specific persians so globe of passions
plus
uh
slash as
slash forward slash then star which
means everything we can here specify
everything that's decom but we don't
need to do that because we know that we
don't have jpeg images or something like
that in our folders so everything inside
the part
of the of the passing which are or
everything is dcom so the globe will
return a list of
all that
it will return a list of all that
passions not passive but slices decom
slices now what we have to do we need to
know how many uh
which will be sparked but we know we
need to we need to know how many percent
we have how many slices we have to do
that we need to to
calculate the length of
this
uh of this list because as i said globe
will return a list of parts of each
slice now we need to
take this
one here and calculate the length of
this list which will be list of but i
will just control x
so land the same thing here so we
calculate the land so let's what will be
the land
for example if we have 100 slices we
will have 100
parts which will be a list of 100 item
now this is the length which will return
it will return 100 because as we said we
have 100
now we need to divide it by the number
of slices that we want to create which
is 64 in our case so divided by 64 here
so when we divide by 64 means that we
will know how many folders we want for
us we are putting here integers okay
this 64 we can leave it 64.65 we can
leave it 64 or we can create a
variable for example that takes the
number 64. then we use it but we don't
care about that we will put it 64 but
because as i told you i will give you
the code at the end of this course and
everything will be clean and all these
for loops etc will be inside functions
but you can you can just call them and i
will show you how you can clone the
github repository etc but at the end for
now i am just explaining how does it
look how does it work in case you have
problems in case something differs from
your project to my project in that case
you can know how to fix these problems
okay otherwise you can just use the
final part of this course using github
cloud repository and no problem with
that
now
as i was saying this number of folders
we needed to know how many folders we
need to create so or how and not all and
and i am saying and in how many groups
we need to divide our passions now after
having this number of slices what we
need to do we need to move the
slices from
the specific folder which is here
[Music]
for example here we have all the slices
what we need to do we need to take 64
from them and move them into a folder
that we will create which will be a
subfolder or subpassion of lever zero so
now let's start doing that loop so it
will be a for loop that range does go
goes from how many folders at first
because what we need to do we need to
create the folder first and move the uh
passing or the slices from the
from each person into that folder that
we have created so what we need to do we
have to create at first they pass the
folder where we want to to put the
slices for that what we have to do we
have four
e in range for example
now we said that we need to know how
many paths how many folders we need to
create so we have number
of folders
so
we will pass by the number of folders we
if we have four
if this value equal to four which is the
number of folders will be four so we
this for loop will pass four times if we
create the
folder then we will write the part where
we will move the
slices into that folder but now we have
to go
step by step now we have to do that
after doing this we need to create
a directory but before that we need to
specify what what is the final or the
part
of the output which means how
where we want and how do we call the
folder of our outputs of our of our
group so what we will do here we need to
give a name for example output
but for example or output path name
something like this what we have to do
we need just to
we will reconstruct it because we have
the output part which is this one this
one is the final output part where we
want to put everything but
we don't need to put just here we need
to create another subfolder which will
have the same name of the passing which
is this one plus a underscore and the
sub folder which will be the i the i
here so it will be 0 1 2 3 etc
so to do it is just to put here
os
dot path dot
join this function always that part that
join is something that just to join two
folder two parts for example i have path
one
slash
part two
comma sorry
if i have this so this from this
function always that part that's joined
what it will do it will do just part one
slash
but two that's what it will do this uh
function so we don't need to worry about
it
so for us what we have we have the final
output there which is out
there outputs
this one which have we have i have i am
putting here then this is the main
output of the labels then we need to put
the name of the passion which will be
here passion name
then we need to add the underscore plus
the sub folder which is here plus it is
a string so we don't need to think about
it you can we can put just plus here and
it will add it to the part so plus and
we said we have underscore then the name
of uh not the name but the index of that
subfolder so which will be the i here
but now i is a antigua we need to
convert it into string to do it is just
to call the function str
and i so what does it mean this it will
create something we just i will run it
to show you how does it look
i have here print out put
but name you will see what does it look
this one just run it it will create this
part which which doesn't exist for now
for now we have this part which exists
which is this is the output here output
part but now we added this lever zero
this is the name of the first passion
and this is the underscore zero and now
here it should be underscore one but for
our case if we have a number of passes
so i want just to say see something i
think there is something wrong here
because we should have zero and one not
zero one here because we didn't go to
the next one
otherwise even maybe the
i would just ah i know why because
here we have for this first passing we
have 76
uh
slices okay so the first passion we will
create the first because when we divide
this by 64 it will give us one one comma
something in that case we cannot create
one comma something folders we create an
antigen folder it should be one folder
so we will we will take 64 first passing
but the other 10 we don't need them and
in this case you don't worry about the
10 slices is not a problem okay
so
this is why we have only one
one passing one
subfolder
and same thing for the second one here
we have
123 so in this in this case for example
it will take the
first
64 slices but the others it will not
take them okay but don't worry about
this there is no problem i am taking 64
because there is other passing that are
having less than that we can put a
number less than this for example we can
put 50 or something but i don't think
that it is a good idea because we lose
some information for us in average in my
case i took this number of slices
because here if i will take for example
50 so in the first passing i will lose
more than
more than when i was 64 because if i
will use 50 so i will lose 25 slices
here so and the more we go with small
number of slices more than the training
will be
will be slow and it will be it won't be
accurate because we will put only number
of slices like 30 or 40 it will not be
something
very accurate so the more slices we put
the more better we have because in my
project in another project where i was
doing tumor segmentation i was using a
groups of 128 slices because i had
passage with much number of slices for
that i could use
128 slices and it was very good number i
tried more than that and less than that
but it was 128
the best one if we if i put more than
that it can be good accurate but it will
take time talking about the training
time
the training because when we launch the
training you will see that it will take
time so more the more the
number of slices you take more than the
epoch will take time in each each time
okay
so for that i don't recommend you to
take a very large number and not very
low number
in some cases you will lose some slices
but it is okay don't worry about that so
for that i am using 64 here now you see
what will happen about this
name just what we need to do that what
this function will do just to create
this name now what we have to do because
as i told you this part doesn't exist so
we need to make it exist so we need to
create a folder with this part so that
we can save our slices in this part so
to do this
just use the os library so os that's
amca the which is make directory and
here what we need to do of course the
output
parts name so this
os
library will make directory for this
output
part name so we will have these two
folders created for me i have only two
but imagine with me you have 131 or 30
baskets or more than that so
this function or this loop will create
folders for each group of bastions don't
worry about this now after doing this
what i have to do is now after making or
after creating the the folder we need to
move the images into that folder so to
do this it is easy just we have four
now we have
we this because this first loop will
pass by all the passions and this one
will pass by all the groups or all the
sub folders now we will pass by all the
the files or all the slices that we have
in each passion so what we have to do is
just we have e because what we need to
do we need to know where or when the
file is
when we are more because
i'm saying that if we have something
like
we need to know in which index we are we
are so that we can stop the loop when we
pass the 64 uh slices so here we have
four e because i tell how to use i will
need it then i need to refer to the file
because
this e is the only the index but now i'm
going to talk about the file which is
the confirm so for e and file of course
in because when we use only one variable
here we use the range but now we are
using two
which i am talking about two
the first one will take the index and
the second one will take the five so we
need to use the enumerate
enumerate
rate function and now here what we have
to put that we have only the name of the
passions with the part but before doing
this we need to know always the path
the passion sorry
but
when we we have a uh a
we if i will put only the passings it
will be just the folder but what we need
to do we have to return all we have to
return the list of the passings the same
thing that we did just here we have the
globe and because this one will globe
and passing plus this star it will
return all the passions or all the
slices that we have in the group or in
this folder or passions so i just need
to copy this
put it here
so what we are saying now
four
e and five in enumerate so this file
will have the
the the part of each d com slice of the
first pass hint for example in the first
iteration so what we need to do we need
to take it return it and then after that
we need to move it into the new folder
or to the folder that we have created so
what we have to do
now
after
taking the iteration from the group we
need to move it so to move this
file we have to use as i told you the
function
sharp till like this so shots will have
a function called move this move
function will move the file to
the uh directory that we want which is
now here we have the file and the
directory or the output file will be
here the output the folder folder that
we have created the output part name so
what i am saying here we have created
the file now we will pass by all the
files or all the decon files of that
specific passing and move them into that
into that folder which is the output
name for name but there is nothing here
that stops the loop we need something
that stops the loop so how to stop it we
need to know where we this the
iterations of the loop are in the same
uh number of slices that we specified
which is 64. but we need to do it before
moving because if we are already passing
the 64 slices we don't need to move
other by other slices so just here put
but now we need to put here if
we said that the i here is the index of
the slices which is the iterations so if
i
equal to the number of slices which is
in our case 64 plus one which is when we
pass it by one we need to stop the loop
which is using the break
function so when we call the break it
will stop this loop which means we will
not move more slices and it will go back
here and go to the next iteration to
move the new uh
so it will go to new iteration it will
create a new subfolder and move the next
64 slices to the next to that new
subfolder etcetera etcetera until
finishing all the subfolders and go
moves to the next passions etc etc now
let's try this and see how what does it
do so just put here
and you can see that now it is done
let's see
our folders
as we said here we have liver and we
have decon files labels and you can see
that it has created the lever zero we
said that we couldn't create lever one
because there is not enough number of
slices to create it so we have zero and
if we go we have 64 65 number 65 slices
okay i think that i miss one so i maybe
we can just leave that
this one i can just leave it on but not
a problem 64 or 65 not a problem but you
can see here that we have created
groups of 65 slices for this one and for
this one and everything and if you have
more than that i am i am using for
example only two two buttons to show you
but if you have more than that you will
see that it will create number of
folders or subfolders of each passion so
if you have a spacing with 600 slices so
it will create i don't know 10
10 or less maybe eight eight or seven
subfolders each subfolder contain 65
number of slices and of course if you
want to change this number of slices
just change this number which is 64 here
just changes i i didn't make a variable
for that because i told you that i am
just showing you but at the end of the
course you will get a full function that
has
at the inputs the input path output part
the number of slices and it will do
everything so that was how to create the
the decom groups now the next step is to
convert these decom groups and of course
i forget to to say that now what we have
we did for the labels now we we need to
do it for the images so what you need to
do just to change here
instead of labels you put images
and the same thing here
images and if i will re-run it this
again this we don't need to run but
otherwise
now if i will run this again
it will do the same thing but for
the images now we have the labels if i
will go to the images you can see that
it has created folders with 65 slices so
that's what all you need to do create
put here labels and after that you need
to put images and it will do for all
your passions after doing all this now
we will go to the next step as i was
saying to convert this nifty group to 65
i just need to change this because i
made this wrong so i need 2.65
now we have 60 groups of 65 slices we
need to convert them into nifty files so
that's what we will do in the next step
now
let's talk about how to convert the
deconfiles that we have created which
are 65 slices into one nifty
file which we will use uh for the
training etc etc
so to do that there is only one function
and you can do it in one line i am
talking about only one file nifty file
we can do it in one line and
which we have
multiple files we can create a loop to
do that
let's do it step by step with you i
didn't want to write it and start
talking about it i prefer to write these
lines of code with you so that you
understand understand each line what
what what we are doing with each line of
code and of course at the end i will
provide the final code only in the
training part it will be a very big loop
for that i need to write it before start
explaining but all these problems
pre-processing parts i will explain them
like this and i will write the code with
you and if i will make some mistakes you
will see it live with me so that you
will not do these mistakes okay
so to do this conversion that we will
need a package called dcom to nifty so
this library the continuity will do all
the work so if you don't already have it
installed on your pc we need you can
install it using pip install
here since we are using jupyter notebook
so we need to add this
and pip install and then rewrite the
name of the library or or of the package
for us i said that it is dcom
to
nifty something like this so when you do
it we will run this cell if you want to
run the cell here just click on shift
enter and it will be run
and we'll wait a little bit when you see
this star here means that this cell is
running we'll wait until this is the
only problem with jupiter notebook you
cannot see all the execution lines or
what is happening you can just see the
final
output here and as you can see we have
successfully installed nifty to decal
so after installing it i will just
delete this by clicking on the cell and
click two times on the
two times and it will delete the cell
now let's import it here what we have to
do just we click import
dcom
to
nifty and we will run the cell because
we need to we will need these two
libraries os or basic operating system
just to create the paths and this d com
file or yes and this d com just
we needed to do the conversion
so the thing that you need to know is
when we
will use this library we need only one
function called dcom series to nifty
that there is another function but i
don't recommend you to use it because it
will not give you the access to
to make it or to rename your files which
mean if you have only one nifty file
that you want to create you can use that
function and in that case i don't
remember the name of this function but
i think it is the com
the community but i think it will
convert repository but uh i i don't
recommend you to use it because as i
told you if you have only one passive it
is okay but if you have multiple
passions you will not have the access to
change the name or to specify the name
of each passion so in this in this case
if you have ten passions it will use the
same name for all the passions in that
case you will see only the final
passings for that case you need to use
the
decom series to nifty so this function
will has two parameters the first one is
the part of the folder where you have
your nifties and the second parameter is
the part where you have
when you want to save your nifties plus
of course the name
of your file
now
let's talk about
our data here we have
code
the control nifties
i don't remember what i put it
is here level
then the confines
and when we did the confines we created
the dcom groups we have the images and
the labels here so the images and as i
showed you i am using only two passions
because i don't want to waste time
running all these codes because i have
already created and prepared all the
data so i am using only two so that you
can see but don't worry about that
because the loops that i am creating
will pass by all the passing so if you
have two it will cover two if you have
ten it will contain ten if you have 100
it will convert 100 so don't worry about
that
so as i told you we have two parts we
need to convert for the images and for
for the labels to do it what we have to
do is just to take the part here
so this part is the common part which
that is the images and there is labels
we will need it let's write it just here
so i will write for example
in
path
something like this
and let's just save it and i recommend
you to use the forward slashes because
sometimes the backward slash make
problems not for example here but if you
have
slash
r or slash t or slash n it will make a
problem so i recommend you to use these
slashes
forward slash so now
this path is the part where there is the
images and the labels now let's start by
converting the images
and you can see that in the folder of
images there is two folders this folder
contains 65 slices and second one as
well now what we have to do what
we will start by the images for example
let's put here to make it easy we can
just use the os but to make it easy here
let's make images so this part is for
the images
let's
make here
images the same thing for
for the labels
something like this and the folder
called i don't know label labels
with s
something like this so now we have the
the parts of the input images and the
inputs labels and you remember that in
each part of these there is or there are
uh all the uh
all the passions or which are all the
folders that having group of slices of
each passion as like this here
now
what we need to do we need to return a
list that has part of this file or this
folder and part of this folder etc etc
so if you remember we used this type of
uh
of
groups of or of
make of returning all the group of all
the files or all the folders from each
from a specific folder using this
kind of functions because we said that
globe when we put globe and we put a
path inside that globe function and we
add this forward slash then star means
that this globe
function will return a list of parts of
all the files inside that folder so for
us for example we have this part of
images so the globe function of this
part
will return
to will return a list of two files or
two items the first item is the folder
of this file and the second item would
be a folder of this file like this so
that's what we'll do so to make it easy
what we can do we can just add the globe
here but before that we need to add the
forward slash star means that everything
that uh that is in that folder which is
images and here the same thing
everything in the labels
now we as i told you i need to return
because here now we are writing the
paths and the parts so the preferably we
will not write it at the same line but
you get it you can write everything in
one line but i don't want to do it so
that's just
maybe some of you are not familiar with
python so preferably i will write
everything in each each thing in
specific lines so that you understand
how did we go from
from the step to the next step etc etc
okay so here we can create a new
variable called list of images
something like this
and as i told you we could do it in the
first line but i just want you to see
how we will use this part to create the
list and how we would use the list to
create the nifty files now here as i
told you we have globe and in the globe
function what we will do we put only the
parts
for example now in images so this one
here if i will run this code if i will
put here list
images if i will run this one as you can
see as i told you we have two parts the
first one is for the first passion and
the second one is for the second and
here we have images and the same thing
for the
for the labels if we create lists
labels
labels then here we have globe and in
path
i don't know what i can type
labels okay now if we do the same thing
here i will just put labels
and now as you can see the same thing we
have first passing second passing but
here we have labels now these two lists
contains the folders of each uh of the
passing of each for the images and for
the labels now after doing this we need
i will delete this now what we need to
do is just to convert each folder so the
function i will just write write it here
the function is d com
to
nifty as i told you the same name of the
library now what we have to do is just
to write the name of the function that
we will use and as i told you the
function is d com to the d com series to
nifty so when we are we are using a
library we want to call it to call a
function you can just write decode
then
series
then 2 then
[Music]
nifty very easy dcom series to nifty
very easy function if you are using
visual studio code maybe
the the editor will suggest it for you
but as you can see it is easy the com
series to nifty this is the name of the
function if it doesn't exist you will
got an error but just try to search for
it but this is the name the comp series
to nifty as i told you there is two
parameters or there are two parameters
the first parameter is is when we put
the input folder
the folder that contains all the nifty
files
and the second parameter will contain
the path where you want to save your
nifty file and where
and what is the name of your
output which is 95 so the first thing as
we said is the input part
here we have this list which contains
two parts and these two parts are the
input parts that we need so if we take
for example
list
images
and we put something like zero means
that we are talking about the first part
if we want to take talk about the second
one we will put one if you have 100 you
put 100 or 99 because it starts from
zero so 99 means the final or the last
uh passing that you have in your 500
passengers so that means that this
indexes will change the
passing that we want to convert
and in our case we said that we have i
have two but i will not just just put
zero and then put one because it is not
general for us i want to write a generic
code for everyone if you have two three
four five any number of passings you
have it will work for you i am talking
about the code
for that we need to pass this
this function because this function will
do everything all what we need to do is
to create a loop that will pass by all
the passions so for that case
what i will do
i will just write here for
passions for example
in
then we said that in what in all the
files that we have or all the passing
that we have and the passion that we
have we have we have the same thing for
me i have two but we have two folders we
have images and labels let's start by
images then we will go to labels so the
parts that we have are here list
images
this first one
this first list contain the parts of the
images then
here we will put the same thing with the
columns
and just make space now
this function this for loop will pass by
my two passions for you you have more
than that so it will do it for you
now before doing that we need to create
the output files or the output
parts okay
to do it what we need to do we can just
do it manually or you can write a code i
prefer doing my doing it manually
because you so that you will know where
you are where you are saving your uh
your files so for me i will start by
creating a new folder here
i will give it the name for example
nifty
files so now we will have the nifty
exact final nifty files in this
in this folder now let's go and create
two folders one for the images and one
for the label
so let's start by images
and the next one is for
labels okay now we have i will take just
this part
then we will add images and labels
we can we can write it here
so out
path
images something like this
and now let's do
the thing i know that i am writing
everything here like maybe we don't need
to write everything here we can make a
script that does that create the folder
and does everything but as i told you
maybe some of you are not familiar with
python so i prefer to use this so you
will understand what why i am doing this
and maybe
you maybe if you are trying your this
code because that happens to me when you
are trying to use a code of someone else
and you will get an error in your code
and you will not understand where this
error comes from because you you it is
it wasn't you who write the code and you
don't know where what are the steps and
how can you fix your error etc etc for
that case i am trying to write it with
you so if you use it it doesn't work for
yours for your task you will know how to
change something how to change the
folders or how to change the files etc
etc for that i am taking time for that
but sorry about this because i didn't
like the old the old way which is just
writing the code and give it to you
because i don't prefer it okay
now
as i said we have images and the same
thing for the labels i will just copy
this and paste it
here we have labels
and the same thing here
labels okay
now after doing this what we have to do
just to i will just rerun this because
we need to
save these files in the system now as i
told you we have to
pass by all the passions but before
doing this as i told you here we have
two parts or two parameters the first
one will take the inputs folder the
second one will take the output folder
so for the input folder as we said we
have parts that are in this list so here
we have passions
so because in each iteration
this variable passions will take one
part from the list so if you have one it
will be of the only one if you have two
it will turn two times the first part
then the second part if you have ten
parts or ten passions it will run t ten
times etc etc for that case the first
thing here we will put only the part of
this uh passion
then the next parameter or yeah next
parameter on that argument will take the
output path plus the name of your
passion so the output part here because
we are taking talking about the images
so the output part here is the image so
we can use something like os.pat
dot join
why i am using this so that we can join
the output part plus the name of your
passions so in this case the output part
here for the images is out but then
images this is the output part of the
images then the name of your passions we
will we need to return it we can just
make uh
the i here from the index and make
passion 0 1 2 3 etc but maybe in some
time because here there is something we
need to talk about here for example not
liver in the groups imagine with me you
have maybe 10 or 100 passions and for
example for the first person you have
two groups so you have level 0 0 level 0
1 level 0 2 3 etc so something like this
and at the end you want to know
which path is exact because you have
created maybe three or four groups but
all of these groups belongs to the same
passions so maybe at the end you want to
know which person had that problem and
i will not say maybe because you need it
you should know because when you want to
say that this passing for example if you
are doing tumor segmentation you will
you need to know which person has tumor
so because if you just create groups and
rename them you will not know at the end
which pass it has tumor for that when
you create these groups you need to know
at the end which uh
which passions for that you need to save
the name of the passion plus the index
for that case here when we will do the
conversion we will not change the name
we'll just extract as we did here
you remember you remember here
not this one remember this line what we
did here just we returned the name of
the pass hand and we'll do the same
thing we'll return the name of the
passage and use it in the saving here so
i will just copy this
and paste it in my for loop and now i
have the password is the same because we
are using the same this is very good
thing when you do unique stuff so you in
each if you will write 200 lines of code
you will remember the name of variables
because if you put multiple and or
random
names of variables you will get problems
at the end of your uh coding because
in some in some case maybe we are coding
now after one month you want to read
your code you will not understand what
this variable is doing because all of us
had that problem that calling your
variables a equal and it will work but
as i told you after one month if you
will read your code you will not
understand why did you put that for that
i am putting in images in past images
output images labels etc etcetera
so
now here we have the outward spots we
need to join it with the name of the
passion which is here passion's
name
and that's it passion's name but there
is something else passing's name will be
only the name of the folder which will
be lever
here for example lever 0-0
underscore 0 not that sorry so
but we need the extension because this
is the name of the passions so if we
have images we need to put dots jpeg
that's png that's steve etc and for our
case we need to put the uh
the extension of our of our files which
are nifties for that case we need to add
the extension which is a string of
course so that's nii
if you put just that and i i it will
create a nifty file but it will not be
compressed if you need to compress you
need you need to compress it after but
you can just add dot
z if you do it like this it will convert
the d columns into nifties and compress
them at the same time so if you don't
need the compressed files you can't put
just that's an ii
but if you need them converted so you
need to put that g z
something like this so now this loop it
will convert all the passions or all the
images or the passions but the images or
their volumes
then we will do the same thing for the
labels so just let's run this
and you can see that we have star here
saying that this cell is running
so it will not take a lot of time so
don't worry about that
let's just wait so that's it now let's
go to our
nifty files images and these are our two
files that we have created let's try to
open one of them we have 3d slices there
just to make sure that the files that we
have created are
good let's try it
[Music]
it will open in any second now
so
let's take for example the first one
drag it here
and you can see that we have only
the maximum here is 64 which is which
starts from 0 into 64 which are 65
slices so these are the slices that we
have created and this is the good point
because you will have unique number of
slices for all the passions so in this
case in the training you will not have
any problem with your data
so now we are making sure that the
function is great correct everything is
good let's do the same thing for the
labels here just change the name into
labels
and
the same thing for the bot
let's go here
labels and rerun it again
and it will convert the labels or to
create labels
you see that sometimes it take few times
when i say a few times few seconds i am
saying not few minutes or something like
this because it is converting then
compressing the file for that it take
few maybe 10 to 15 seconds
but
it is working now these are two other
files of uh
of of these are the labels the file of
the labels and these are for the images
and as i told you don't worry about the
number because here this for loop it
will pass by all your passions so if you
have 10 it will convert 10 if you have
more it will convert more if you have
less it will convert less so that was
how to convert the comp files in the
next step we'll talk about because all
these things that i am talking about are
when you have data already segmented or
already already labeled but maybe let's
suppose that you have passions but you
don't have your labels so for that case
i will show you how you can do the
segmentation by yourself using etk snap
now let me show you how you can segment
your
data if you segment or label your data
so if you don't have
segmentations because if you have
already downloaded data from the net in
this case you will find that the labels
but maybe
as we were saying at the beginning of
the course maybe the data that you will
download doesn't have the same
number the same extension so in this
game i don't know or maybe they are
using another task for example they are
doing uh
liver tumor segmentation but you won't
use that
data for only liver segmentation not the
tumor level segmentation for that case
maybe you need to correct or to re label
your data so for this
purpose i am showing you how you can do
it yourself
for that i am using etk snap that i
showed you how you can download it and
install it now let's start by i will
just make this window bigger
i will take this here now let's go to
deliver i am not a doctor but i am sure
that this is delivered okay so
now let's do
some segmentation i will show you how
you can segment some slices but you will
get the point because you can do the
same thing with 3d slicer but i found
that to these slices is a little bit
complicated in term of segmentation but
etk snap is the easiest software ever to
do this kind of stuff
it is old but it is very easy for us i i
prefer to use it for segmentation for
example i will show you how you can
create a new segmentation and i will
show you how can you can correct the
segmentation even for so if you have
already some segmentation and you know
you need to just modify it or collect it
not to redo it again so i will show you
how you can do it let's create one save
it and load it to change it after
now
to do the segmentation you just need to
go here you have clear label we'll use
it after try to choose one label so for
us we have only one thing or one organ
that we want to segment which is the
liver so we used label one if you have
multiple organs that you want to create
so you start by for example label one
means that you will do or you will
segment the first organ then if you want
to segment the second organ you choose
the label two so it will know it will
give two different values to each label
and two different colors etc but for us
we are segmenting only one organ which
is the liver so let's choose the first
one which will be in red now let's
choose our brush so click on this one
here paint brush like this
and you choose the shape the shape it
can be square or
circle something like this or something
generally here i prefer to use this and
this thing here just bar here just to
control the size of your brush something
like this and you can use these
for sometimes i used i used to use this
3d
check box here but what does it mean
because i will show you with the 3d and
without the 3d when you do without the
3d if you segment this slice
means that you have segmented only the
slice if you go to the next one you will
not you you will not see any
segmentation
but using the treaty it will segment two
or three
slices at the same time depending to if
the slices are similar or not
i don't prefer to use the 3d while doing
the segmentation but i use it most most
of the time i use it when i want to
correct my segmentation in that case i
prefer to use the 3d or to delete the
segmentation so that it will be fast but
when doing the segmentation or doing the
labels i prefer to use the 2d normal 2d
i segment each slice by itself so let's
show you how to do it for one slice and
you will get the point for all the
slices now just select as i showed you
here the shape and everything is good
first label the shape here and the the
size of that brush here and let's start
just clicking and labeling like this as
you are painting
i am not a good painter but
let's try to do it
try to make your segmentations as tight
as possible and try to cover only the
lever
so that's the code will not get confused
with the other organs because you see
that it is in grey scale and everything
is similar so if you don't segment very
well
the mother will start segmenting
everything in
the body
well
not too bad it is too bad actually but
we correct it
let's make it bigger
here
so that it will be fast
oof we did this
now let's go to the next slice to do to
go to next let's just scroll something
like this and you see that for this
first slice is segmented the next one is
not segmented so you do the same thing
here
like this i will just
do it
to have time because it will take time
if i will start painting
so the same thing for the other ones
just like this
and do not don't do the same thing that
i am doing because i'm just showing you
but all these things need to be
corrected that i wish i will show you
how to correct that but as you can see
don't do it
that's it's
the same thing for all the slices okay
so now let's save one
segmentation and we will reload it to do
the correction for example this part or
something so that you will understand
how to correct your segmentation
now to segment to save it go here in
segmentations
and save segmentation image
and that's it just give the name and it
will be saved at the same
part where you have your images
otherwise if you want to change change
the path just clicking browse and change
the path let me give it the name for
example test segmentation
something like this and it will be saved
with the same part of my image which is
this one
now let's just close
all these images
without saving
we we just closed everything now let's
just let's try to reload our uh
segmentation that we have created now
this is the segmentation that we have
saved drag and drop here
but here when you do it just click on
load as segmentation otherwise you can
go to in segmentation open segmentation
and choose the path but if you have
already the folder just drag it drag it
and drop it here and click in load as
segmentation okay
and it will be opened
put this one here
i'm going in wrong side
so
these are the slices that we have
segmented now let's i will show you how
you can correct these segmentations for
example let's try this one
let's collect this part here and you
will get the point and you will see that
it is very easy remember when we want we
wanted to segment this part we we
clicked on segmentation or label one if
we want to segment something else we
click on label 2 and it will get in the
green color and it will segments another
organ now we want to clear the
segmentation of we need to delete or
edit segmentation for that case we click
on clear segmentation that's easy click
in the brush
check the size and check the shape and
the size for example
and now if i will go here click
you can see that it is deleting the
segmentation
like this it is clearing and if i will
do this this we do the same thing
so now you get the point how to do the
segmentation how to clear the
segmentation and how to save it now when
doing this if i want to save it again i
will just click here save you can just
click here in save with the same name if
you want to save another file
so because here if you click here it
will
pass this plus this new segmentation in
the last one so we will lose the first
segmentation but if you want to save it
as a new segmentation just click in save
as and that's it
so that was how to do this segmentation
now you have you get the point if you
don't have already the segmentations
with your data you can do the labeling
using this etk snap software after doing
this you can pass by the way that we
talked about before which is converting
into groups and after that converting
into nifties because
we so i told you why we needed to do
this because if your data is ha
has the same number of slices for all
the passions or something similar like
100 110 120 90 something like this maybe
you don't need even to do this type of
conversion because
100 or 90 or 110 is nothing you can just
resize them and put them at the same
at the minimum which is 9 90 slices and
put all your passions at that's 90
slices but if you have passions with
ones or with 90 others with 200 so if
you do resize you will lose more than
100 slice for some passions for this
case i recommend you to create the
groups of specific number of slices as
we did before 65 and it's up to you you
can choose any number of slices you want
so that was for this in the next part we
will start doing the pre-processing
because this part is the preparation of
the data you see that we are just
preparing the data in the next part we
start doing the pre-process which will
be before the training we do the
pre-process after that we will do the
training so let's see let's do the next
parts in the next few minutes
so before going to the pre-process there
is something that i forgot to talk about
which is the images or the groups that
we have created
there is something here
i will go here data set label
then the nifty files
these
so for example this is for the images
that we have created and this is for the
labels
so there is something in some cases when
you
for example you have a passage with 600
slices or this is not strange because
you will find dataset does have pass
into its 600 800 and more than that
so don't don't be confused about that
but
this is not the point what i am saying
or trying to say is maybe in this 600
slices
only 100 or 200 slices that are useful
or maybe if you have passing with 300
slices only 100 or 150 slices are useful
the others are not useful
so when you create groups of 65 slices
you will find some sub passions which
are groups that we have created for
example this one
contain nothing which means that the
labels are empty which means that part
of the body that you
subtracted doesn't have anything which
means all labels are empty for that case
these type of groups or these type of
subpassions will cause a problem with
the accuracy of your problem of your
program or of your your mother sorry
for that case preferably you need to
take or to delete these parts because
they are useful because in your 65
passions you will have indeed you will
have some empty slices but if you
calculate the
difference between the empty slices and
four slices you will find something like
the same or that is not a big difference
but when you take a sub
subpassing which will be one input so it
will be one input without any label so
imagine with me that you are doing a
program of classification between cat
and dog and you put with your data you
put images of
rabbits or something like this in the
training so the program will be confused
we will say that this image of rabbits
is not useful i will not use it you need
it for the classification so why you are
putting it
in the inputs so i hope that you get the
point for that case when you create and
this is something good when you create
small groups for this case you will
delete all the parts of the parts that
you don't need
so for that case
when you create the groups you need to
find or to specify which are the
slices that are empty or the groups or
subpassing that are empty so that you
can delete them for that i wrote a
script for you it contains only two or
three lines of code so don't worry about
it which is useful just to show you
which are the uh
the the files or the passings that
doesn't have any label or any
segmentation for the 65 slices so to do
it we will do it step by step just we
need to import one library
i don't remember if i think we have
already installed niba bell
let's try to import it and see
there is no problem so we need this if
you don't have it just write
beep
something like this pip
install
knee
bubble and run it for me it is already
installed so recommend already satisfied
i will delete it so after importing it
rerun
this cell so this file is this library
will be imported now let's use it so
this new bubble is a function just to
handle the nifty files because what we
will do we will
load each file
which is a nifty file then we will
see the values of the pixels if there is
values between zero uh if there is
values of zero one two and something
like this more than only one value means
that this uh
subpassions contains labels indeed it
contains this the
zero values for the background and the
one for the foreground and if you have
multiple objects you have you will have
two three extra etc
and and if you will find only there is
only zeros means that this part contains
only the background which means there is
no organ there is no lever in that part
so you need to delete it okay this is my
recommendation if you don't want to use
it you want to use all your passions you
are free to do it but i don't recommend
you to use multiple
uh groups or subpassions which doesn't
contain anything in that case because
when you put the patients directly with
with random or with random slices having
labels or not at the same time there is
no problem but when you put one input
without any label so this is the problem
so when you create the groups you need
to make sure that you don't have any
empty labels or any empty passions
when i say empty which means there is no
parts that doesn't contain
doesn't contain
lever okay so
let's start coding this as i told you
the first thing that we need to do is to
open the image which will be for example
i will call it image or nifty
file
so to do it we will use the knee barbell
i just need to use this i can use the
shortcut like as nib it is a convention
they are always but you can use directly
bubble but it's convention to use nib as
for knee bubble to make it short so nib
then that's the function load this
function load will load one pass hits so
let's do it for one passing to show you
how does it work then we'll create the
loop that will pass by all the passions
now let's do it let's start by taking
this part for example
here is the is this is the output part
but for us we need it as an input here
because we need this path but you don't
need to use the parts or the files of
the images because the images we are
sure that images are have multiple
values have zeros one and something
between them
but for the material for the medical
images you will find values between
minus three thousand or minus one
thousand into plus one thousand don't
worry about that this is the medical
imaging welcome to the club
so
what you have to do is
using the labels because we said that we
need to see if there is label if there
is foreground in that part of the body
so for that we need just to check the
labels because labels will specify the
foreground and the background we cannot
see that in the images
so let's take the path of this
output images which will be our input
here
so i will just put
in
put
nifty
file
path for example
and
that's it's ctrl v
so this is the all
paths for now we take as i said it will
take only one passion so i will just
take the name here
after using after trying with one
passing i will show you how we will just
add a loop that will pass by all the
passes don't forget to add the gz
because the value the files here are
compressed so that's gz
now let's what we will do just we will
load this passions which will be here
inputs
in
[Music]
put something like this
input nifty file but
so if we run this cell there is no error
no problem because we just loaded the
image it is here in nifty file what we
need to do now
there is something in the medical
imaging if you have already some
knowledge about that there is not only
the image exactly which is the array of
the image
we are talking about the nifties or the
decons the same thing there are other
informations like the passive
information the name and age etc there
are value or there are informations
about the pixels the dimensions of
pixels etc will use this in the
pre-processing process pre-processing
sorry we'll talk about them later on but
for now what we need to do we need just
to substitute to extract the value
the matrix or the
array that contains images which are the
slices because what we need to do just
to take this
values or this matrix that has all the
values of the slices and verify the
slices of each passions where there is
only zeros or where there is zero and
one or two or something like that
for that to to to start to subtract or
to extract the array from the image
which is nifty image there is a function
called
getfdata fdata means that frame data so
we can just
create as i told you we can do
everything in one line but i am just
writing every each thing in one specific
line so that you can understand the
steps that we are passing by so here we
have f data which means frame data to do
it just write the name of your passing
which is nifty
file
dot
get f
data
it is a function so we need to add the
parenthesis so this fdf data will
contain the
values of all the slices so it will be
an array of
65 slices because we have passage of 65
and each
65 yes slices or 65 items and each item
is an array of
of an image which contains the values so
we need to know if these values are
contains only zeros or zeros and one or
zero one two three etc for that case we
need to specify the dimensions of this f
data but
using only dimensions will not be the
thing that we need because the images
will just give you how many slices or
something like that but there is a
function in numpy called
unique numpy that's unique so this
function unique will return if there is
or if there are unique values so if you
have only zeros in your function if in
your array so
the unique values will be only zero if
you have zero one two three but
you have multiple one two threes in your
image so it will return only the unique
values that you have in your image
so
for us if the unique values will be only
zeros means that this image or this
passion is contained only zero that
means that there is no lever so we need
to delete it
if this unique function returns zero and
one or more than one value means that in
that case that uh there is something in
the image that is the background and
there is the foreground indeed so to do
it here what we can do as i told you we
can choose the number the uh the
function unique so here what we can do
just i will create another function
sorry about that but as i told you i
want to write everything so i will call
it numpy unique
and now we can i don't remember if i
have not by here we don't have it so if
you don't have numpy just as i told you
just something like this beep install
numpy and it will be installed but for
me i already have it i think
so i will put imports numpy as
and b
something like this so it is already
imported now let's let's use it so np
dot
unique
and here we will put the
array that we have and for us we have f
data this is our unique uh our array so
let's let's let's print this so and be
while using japanese notebook you don't
need to use the print function you can
just write the name of the uh
of your variable and run it it will uh
it will just print it here like this as
you can see and for us for us you can
see that we have zero one two for us we
have more than one value we don't have
only zero means that there is the
background and that is the foreground
for this case we don't need to delete
this passion if we have only zero here
we don't have this one and two we have
only zero means that we have only the
background so this buttons need to be
deleted
i hope that you get it this is the point
that's all what we need so the function
that we need to do is
only to specify the length of this
return or of this unique uh
so what we can do
we can just say if
np
unique
but as we said we need the length of
this
of this variable so length if the length
of this and be unique
is
bigger
than two which means the the length is
not one if there is bigger than two
means that we don't need to delete that
passion
but if this lend is equal to one
means that this passion need to be
deleted so if equal to one let's make
just like print
and let's print this this passion so for
us we'll print this
[Music]
this part because we we are having only
one but we do it for a loop now let's
print it here there is nothing printed
because this passion has foreground and
background so if you are in the case
where there is no foreground and
background you have only the background
so it will be printed now let's do it
for all the passions you have data
database for which
with i don't know hundreds passions
let's do it now
so let's say that labels and just change
put here star
this mean that
this
part contains multiple files so this
star will return everything inside that
folder to do it let's start by
creating the list as we did here we need
to create a list
of
labels
and it is equal to globe then here the
parts
input
parts file uh
a nifty file
then here this
this
[Music]
list of
group of parts will be used in the for
loop as we did before
so now let's just write for
persians in
list labels
then
let's do what we have done here let's
just we can just copy these and use them
there is no problem let's just
pass them here so they will be in the
condition if condition
now what will be happen but just we need
to
change this
because we need to load that specific
passion not the folder here
so here load the passions which is here
for the loop load the patient
and get the frame data from that passion
calculate this unique
then calculate the length if it is equal
to one then print it but we will need to
print the passions so here
sorry i am
passions so we will read it we load it
extract the frame data get the frame
data then
choose the unique calculate the new
unique
values then if it is equal to one the
length then prints let's just run this
and you can see that there is nothing
printed because the
both passings that i have here are
with the foreground and background so
there is no problem but if you have
passions with more because for me or
even my passions that i use in this test
has only one hydrant and second one has
120 or 110
slices so when i created the nifty
groups the nifty the decom groups and
converted them into a nifty which is
which are the sub passions here
they have they should have
slices with the liver because if i had
the
large number if i had pass it with 600
slices for example in this case i will
get definitely definitively i will get
three or more than three groups of
decoms or groups of 65 slices which are
empty so for this case i needed to
delete them
because
in in this in this task i am showing you
only two passions but i have already
prepared the data and i had that problem
and i have deleted all of them
when we start doing the preprocess i
will show you how i created the folders
for the training and for the testing and
we'll do everything together don't worry
about that
now as i told you this is the script
let's verify if you have empty
files in that case it will print them
and you can delete them manually i
wanted to do it with a script to delete
but i had some problems sometimes if you
do something wrong you may delete the
wrong files but if you want to do it you
can just add the line to delete that
button but i don't prefer that i just
want to print them maybe verify them but
it's up to you if you want to delete
them you can just add the delete or the
remove function uh from the chantel that
we used before here
this function gentle you can use it to
delete the file and just put the then
call the gentle down here put the parts
which is the passion of that part of
that passing which is the empty and it
will delete it for you so if you prefer
to do this you can do it
so now after doing i think that now we
have completed everything about the
preparation of the data let's start
doing the pre-process and of course
eventually the training
so now before doing the pre-processing
because
all the functions that you will use or
need to do the pre-process are included
in muni and python
so before doing that we need to install
monae and pytorch and all the
dependencies that we need at the
beginning maybe
in the process we will need some other
libraries but not are they are not the
most important ones but the important
ones are for now monae and pytorch
because they will use them for the
pre-process for training for the testing
etc
for that we need to install them
but before doing that we need to create
to install code cuda
which are the packages for the gpu and
the tool case for the gpu so that we can
do the training using the gpu not cpu
because using the gpu and my training
sometimes it took two days to two days
to be completed because the images are
very big so imagine with me if you have
60 or 100 passions and each passion
contains 300 slices and these 300 slices
we will divide them but i am talking
about the at start so for example if
each pass it will be divided into two or
three parts so multiply your 100 percent
by three so it will be 300
sub passions and each subpassion
contains 60 65
maybe slices so imagine with me how
large your data will be
and we are we will use the 3d monae so
we will do 3d convolutions so it will be
tight it will take time it will be very
slow for us you need to be careful not
to be careful but you need to be aware
about that
you will prepare your data verify it if
everything going well
just run it and leave it for one day or
two days depends to how many passes you
have for me
i remember one
time the training took me two days or
two days or a half when i say two days
means that 48 hours not only two days
just like that
so i have a gpu with gtx
1080 but it does it it wasn't that fast
so you need to be aware about that
because maybe you will say you will say
that i can use collab because when i
they are using collab in their tutorials
but remember that the images or the yes
data that they are using in their
tutorials
are spacings with small number of slices
and they have only 40 passings maybe i
think yeah
and for that the training doesn't take
more much time but if you have data set
with large number of passings and with
large number of slices
be aware that it will take time
especially if you will run it in your pc
because even if you want to run it in
collab
you you i i think that you know that in
collab you cannot run more than 12 hours
if you have a good internet connection
without any cut or something like that
it will it cannot go more than uh one
run it one it cannot go more than 12
hours so you make it you can pay for
call up pro so you will get 24 hours but
as i told you something it took two days
so be aware about that okay and don't be
scared don't be scared if the training
took two days because i am just telling
you that it can it can do that okay
depends on how many passings you have so
to do the installation the first thing
as i told you we need to install the
cuda
you can just go to their website
developers.nvidia.com cuda downloads
otherwise you can just write in google
here coda
download
something like this and go to this
first link
and
you will get cuda toolkit 11
if you have problems because we if we
are using tensorflow it may be a problem
because sensor flow with some versions
of cuda or kodiana if you don't
download or or if you don't install the
specific some specific versions you will
get problems at the end
but with python don't worry about that
because i will show you when we will
install python you will see everything
clearly so don't worry about the
versions if you want to install 11 you
can install it if you want to install 10
you can install it
with no problems
so here we want to i have already this
uh
qdn encoder installed in my pc so i will
not download them again but i will show
you how to do that to do that
then we'll go to the installation part
so for me i am using windows if you are
using linux you can just click in linux
so i will click windows
this
x86
then here the version of windows i have
windows 10 then you want to use it in
network on local i prefer use it in
local and now everything is
set you can just click on download and
something i will just click to show you
and you can choose the directory where
you put your file and it will be
downloaded successfully without any
problem
and after downloading this you just go
here i have them here
open your i will not do it again as i
told you because i already have it but i
will show you when you click on it you
will get the window
let's wait
my pc is a little bit slow these days i
don't know why
but
let's see
so click on run
then choose the directory i will not
click because if i will click it will
start doing the installation so
everything is easy just click in next
next next and everything will be
installed
after installing the cuda now let's go
to kuden and korean is another package
which will be used with cuda so just go
here in developers.nvidia.com
or just you can go here and
[Music]
press download
typos press
download to
dna
okay
so here nvidia cdn
the same thing
and let's go on download cdn
and now to do it you need to have an
account and it is free don't worry about
that you need to have an account
developer account so once you create an
account you can just choose version it
depends to you so for us we have
downloaded cuda 11 so we need to install
this if you have already another version
of cuda so you need to check the version
that you need for your cuda so click on
archive or korean archive so you just
find all these versions so
see which kudi which code that you have
installed in your pc and install the
available or the corresponding kudn
version after downloading it what we
will do we i will show you how to do it
we this is it will be something like
it's like a compressed file when you
decompress it you will find this file
this
folders so that's what you will find so
to install kdnn very easy you just need
to copy and paste these kdn files into
cuda where you you have cuda installed
so if you want to see where your your
cooler is installed what you need to do
just go to your pc
and go here in your desk then your
program files
and you will find the folder here
nvidia gpu computing toolkit
so this folder will be created
automatically when you install kudi and
cuda sorry and if you go here you have
cuda and you have the version if you
have multiple versions you will find
multiple versions here but for me i have
only one so you have you will find this
one
now i will just keep this here i will
open another one
we have
three holdings here downloads and cool
dnl so as i was saying
what you need to do just to copy the
files from the bin of the korean
paste them into bin of cuda
and includes of kodianen just copy them
and paste them in includes of cuda the
same thing for the
lib
copy these go to lib x
64 copy them and go to lib here
and x 64 and paste them here i have them
already so i will not do it again but
you get the point because i have kudian
and all the files are here so just
select all
copy them and paste them here that's all
what you need to do and the last thing
that you need to do is to go to your
system environment and add your
file
the parts of the lib i will just show
you here
properties
advanced parameters
variable systems
if available environment and now if you
go in parts
you will find that i have i don't know
if i can
yes i can move it here now for me i have
these parts the path to the bin to do to
the bin w uh
to the bin
and vvb and the the other one which is
extra cool
t
slash lib64 where you if you will find
them they are all
here
good version
so this is the first part which is the
bin so go to bin
copy this part copy it ctrl c and come
here click in new and paste it and
that's it click enter the same thing for
the other one which is the lib and vp
this
one
and copy it
create a new part paste it and the
same thing for the extra
copy tt
lib64 and copy this and paste it here
and you are and everything is set now
you have installed the i will just
close this
now you have installed your kodi nnn
we will go to this one
here we have installed cuda kudi and now
we need to install monae and python
let's start by mulai the easiest one to
install mona you can just do bip or
conda install so
here we
install
more light
that's it it may take some few seconds
it depends to your internet connection
and because my internet connection is
very bad so it will take
maybe one minute or less let's stop it
for a few seconds
and now you can see that it is installed
now let's
try to install python so to install
pytorch we just we need to go to the
website pytorch.org
okay that's it
and now to inst to download it
because when you go to python.org you
will go to this page just scroll down
here
check the stable version
for me i am using windows if you have
mac or linux you can just select them
after that i want to install them using
pip install if you have you want to use
it what really difference is when you
click encoder it will be could install
instead of beep install but you can see
that some some things will be different
but
when you use for me i am using python
pip install so it will download the
packages from the uh
from the website by touch the website
okay so flip then python because you are
using python now
if you have kuda 11 check code 11 if you
have kuda 10 check code 10
if you don't have gpu and you want to do
your training in cpu i don't recommend
you because it will take one week
so you need to check on cpu so it will
be installed or storage vision touch
audio for us we have cuda 11 because we
installed cuda 11.5 but don't worry
about that 11.3 does the work because
you don't you don't have 10 so we have
the 11.
then copy this lines and we will install
them so for us we are using jupyter
notebook i need to do it
so
here you can see that pip3 you can leave
it pip3 or you can make just pip
where we have pictorially because if we
have installed pip 2 uh python 2 and
python 3 in the same virtual environment
so in that case we preferably need to
use pip
without number means we are talking
about
python 2
if we put pip 3 means that we want to
install this package in the python 3.
for us we have only python 3 we don't
have python 2 so pip it will
install in the python 3. so when we run
this cell the same thing this
installation may take some time depends
to your internet connection
so after doing this everything is set
when we start doing the pre-processing
after installing muni as you can see
mona is installed and the
cuda installed korean installed and now
we are waiting for pytorch
let's
stay for a few seconds
to see this message successfully
installed
yes we have to see it
so now everything is set and you can see
that
the pytorch is installed without any
problem now everything is set we don't
need anything to install for now
i will delete this and this if i will
click for example import monae
it will be imported without any problem
so
now you can see that everything is set
because
i i i started with this because i told
you because we need we will need monae
and pytorch for the pre-process even for
the president only for the training for
that i needed to start by ins by this
installation
so let's start doing the pre-process
now let us let us talk a little bit
about how to do the pre-process so i
will not go to the to the steps uh each
line of code by line
because i have already done videos and
blog posts about everything that we need
to do for the pre-process so you can
find the links here in my website that
is in my picadco you will find a blog
post about pre-processing in detail and
also the youtube video youtube video
about that so you can check it out so
that i will not repeat everything in
each video because i know that if i will
talk about that it will take a lot of
time because only the video about
pre-process i have two parts each part
for 40 minutes or 50 minutes so imagine
with me if i will talk about the
pre-process and this augmentation that
we will come to it later so it will take
a lot of time doing that but there are
already videos that i have done about
that and there are blog posts that you
can read there are code etc but don't
worry about the code because the code
that we will use here
is more
i have i have just ordered it and it is
well done because here it is
you will find the code but it is only
for the pre-process but here
since we are going to do the training
after the pre-process so i have created
some functions instead of just scripts
doing the pre-process i have created
functions that you will find in my
youtube repo in my github repository
don't worry about that
at the end of this course i will be
i will be talking about everything so i
will show you how you can just get clone
this the git cloud this
[Music]
github repository and how you can call
all the functions because you will find
that every function that we will use is
here for example how to calculate the
dice matrix calculate weights everything
we will talk about it later here is the
function that will do the training
because as you know in
python there is no a specific function
as in because if you have used
tensorflow before you will find that
there is that function that feeds mod
that fit so it will launch the training
and is a little bit easier but in python
there is no function
called that fit so you need to write the
loop by yourself and almost all these
things in the training part i took them
from uh pythorg
from sorry from monae
tutorial but i just have done some
changes to make the code clear but we go
we'll come back to this later
and here in the not
in the pre-process
we find all the functions that we talked
about for the creating the groups and
nifty to decom and find the empty
and at the end we we have this function
function prepare which contains the
lines of code to do the pre-process so
everything is here in github but i will
make it clear at the end of this course
and i will show you how you can just
clone the repository use the functions
but before that i just wanted to explain
to you some of these
parts because as i told you i will not
go to everything line by line because
you will find the explanation here but
just to give you a small explanation i
will give you here i will talk a little
bit about some
of the
fun not the functions but
only some transforms that we used here
because if you go in monae's website you
will find that there are tons of
transforms that you can apply in your
data for the pre-process and for the
data augmentation but for us i will not
use all these data all these transforms
sorry i just took smaller
few of them just to make the data clear
but i didn't do like a
huge things for the data because it will
take time and it will take memory and i
don't have that
great gpu to do all these functions
but i will show you how it will look
using only these pre-processings and you
can do it
yourself like this if you want to add
more functions of course it will be
great because you will see the results
at the end they will be acceptable but
if you
train your model for more data than i
that then i am using or you if you do
more pre-process or more data
accommodation of course your model will
be improved better than mine
but we go to this later
now let's talk a little bit about the
pre-process as i told you
here as you can see i have created four
variables each variable contains the
path for the training volumes training
segmentation then the testing volumes
and testing segmentation if you have
already seen the
tutorials of monae in their website you
will find that they are not talking
about testing they are talking about
validation but i prefer to call it
testing because
when we see validation in deep learning
most of the time means that these data
will be used in the training and it can
affect the model during the training but
here of course we are we will because if
you see the tutorials of monae you will
see that they are using actually this
data that they are calling them
validation data
they are using them during the training
but they are not affecting the training
for that
they say always testing data because we
just use them to see what happened but
we don't use the result of that
validation data to do some changes in
the model for that i prefer
calling them testing data and not
validation data but it ups to you you
can call them anything you want but i
don't prefer to call them validation and
if you want to leave the validation you
can do that
so as you can see here the there are
some important things that you need to
keep in mind the first thing
is the name of your folders
i don't i am not saying that you need to
call your folders with the same names
that i am doing but
what you need to do or what what is
important here is that you need to
specify the name the exact name of your
folders because here there is the first
thing
in your path or where you will find your
data the first thing is the main path
which means the directory where you have
all the
folders or all the passions for example
here
for me this is the whole or this is the
main folder which contains four four
folders i will just minimize
this and this directory contains four
folders the first one is the testing
test segmentation where you will find
the masks for the testing
and the second one is the test volumes
and this one training segmentation and
training volumes volumes means the
passions and segmentation here means the
labels okay
so these are the four folders that you
will need so if you are calling them the
same as i am calling them here you can
just leave the code otherwise if you
change these name then you need to
change these names as well here so if
you will go with me at the end and just
fork the github repository and use it
for that case
you need to change your folder's name to
make it easy or otherwise you can change
in the code but maybe the best thing if
you are using the same code the best
thing is to change only the names and
not all the uh not the code okay
and the second thing actually i
i will talk about this later on and i
will show you some examples
but now i will give you just small words
about that
you need to be specified about this
thing here which is the extension of
your files
as i told you we cannot use something
like other types
but nifty so we need to use nifty files
but the second thing here as i told you
here when we add that gz means that this
nifty file is compressed
so if your files are not compressed you
need to delete this dodge gz because if
you leave this the gz
but your files are not compressed means
that this
not this is just defining this line is
just defining the part but here when you
will load your data
and
you don't put the exact extension here
means that the function bell that
will open this volume will not find this
file it will find for example passion
one does nii but it will not find that
gz
in that case it will not recognize that
it is the same passion for that case it
will not open it and you will lose
this passion and imagine me with me if
you're if all your passion doesn't have
this
gz means that your
your code or your program or your own
function will not open any type of data
and it will not open your passions in
that case you will find your data loader
here empty like there is no data and you
can do nothing with that and the problem
here is that you will not know this is
the biggest problem with one eye you
will not know where is the problem you
it will not give you an error here if
you will run this code there is no error
but when you will try to
print no print or you can if you want to
print or if you want to upload your
images in this case you will find that
your data loader is empty and you will
not know that the problem is with the
extension this is what i am saying you
will
you will miss to delete this extension
but the code will not tell you that you
have missed something or there is
something wrong or the directory is
wrong or there is no such a directive
like this because always when we do or
when we put the wrong part
always we get the error saying that this
directory doesn't exist and in that case
you will know what is the problem but
with mona you will not know that you
will find just the data loader is empty
but you will not know that it is empty
because you just forgot to
delete or to add this.gz
the same thing for other stuff but as i
told you i will show you that
in in practical but not for now now now
i am just explaining but after that i
will give you a small things
that will cause problems and i spend a
lot of time trying to
to debug that because
you will not know what is the problem
you know you need to print everything in
your code so that you may find the
problem
for that i will first case i will show
you some of the problems that i found
during my period not pid but during my
uh
master's thesis while i was doing this
project not this project but something
similar but
uh in this case maybe if you will find
or if you will be faced with these
problems you will know how to solve them
so
i try to do there is four
for variables each variable represents
the path for the volume segmentation for
the training volume segmentation for the
testing
the second thing here is to create two
dictionaries the first one is for the
training second one is for the testing
dictionaries is only some
rows and
rows and columns
and this
these are the keywords and these may
cause a problem as well but i will not
talk about them now
so this one is vol for volume this seg
for segmentation so these are two
keywords each one represents a column so
this column is for volumes this column
is for segmentation and in each column
you will find some rows and each row
contain the path for each passion so the
first for example first row first column
we represent the path to the volume of
the first passion this the first row and
the second column will represent the
segmentation of the first questions etc
etc these for the training and same
thing for the testing
and you will find all the explanation
about these in my blog post and in my
youtube video about that so just i am
just giving you a small uh
recalculation but you will find
everything there
and now let's talk about this transform
function this transform function you can
see that there is this function composed
which is you can find this in python and
idea are using the same thing here
compose is a function that allows you to
use or to apply multiple transforms at
the same time not to apply a first
transform to the image and the output
image passes to the second image that
the second function that will do the
second transform etcetera etcetera but
doing using this compose function you
don't need above you don't need to worry
about that you just need to define which
are the transformers that you want to
apply and it will do
that it will do that by itself you don't
need to specify which one the first the
second but here it will take this order
this one will be applied the first this
one second extra extract until this last
and about that
some of these functions need to be in
the exact order but others doesn't
matter you can add them any way you want
so the first one that need to be at the
exact order which is this one which is
load image
load image because before doing any
transform you need to load the image
first
so to load the image you need to use
this load image d d is for dictionary
because you can use more line with these
dictionaries or you can use them just
with opening images without using this
dictionaries so when you do that without
dictionaries you need to delete this d
but if you are following my code or if
you see the code doing by mona they are
always using dictionaries because it's
fascinating but it facilitates the ev
everything in the code because if you
use just script with all the parts it
will be something painful but here you
know that when you specif when you put
you or when you use the keyword wall
meaning you are talking to volumes here
segmentation because you will find that
everywhere when we talk about how to
show images or how to train images
everywhere will use these keywords so it
is something that will help you and not
be painful for you so i recommend you to
use this way which is the dictionaries
but if you prefer the other way of
course you can use it and you need to
delete this d at the end of all the
functions okay
so after loading the function the
passion sorry you need to add a channel
because as i told you in our case there
there are two uh
for us for now there are only two
challenges for the output there is the
first channel that represents the pixel
for pixels or the mask for the
background and the second channel will
represent the mask for the foreground in
that case you need to add a channel here
so that you will have two channels okay
okay
but
you will add another one for the for
to specify the the batch size but it
will be added here from the data loader
don't worry about that and of course as
i told you you will find everything here
explained in this blog post okay
now
after adding a channel there is
something that you need to do which is
changing the pixels the dimensions the
pixel dimensions of your passions this
is as well one of the important things
that you need to keep in mind
because what you will do here i am using
pixdem
and this name here because i am using
the speaks theme in this in the
parameters or in the arguments of my
functions that i have created and you
can see that i am putting here 1.5 for
the width 1.5 for the height and 1.0 for
the depth of the pixel
so
in your case you will find maybe your
because the problem here with the public
dataset you will find that you will find
some passions having uh
two by two by two others zero five by
zero five by zero five others one by one
by one and if you use them as they are
you will find we will cause a problem
for that case you need to put them at
the same dimensions okay for this case
you need to use this function which is
spacing which will change the spacing
and puts
all the dimensions the same and the
problem that i told you here you will
find the problem here with with the
depth especially because with the width
and height if you define just a constant
number here it will fix the problem but
with the depth it will cause a problem
if you don't choose the right value here
i am using one because i found that with
data there is no problem with the value
one but in others it may cause problem
we'll come back to this later when we
will talk about all the problems that
you can face during
using monae and
deep learning for medical imaging
now
the next thing i will not talk about
this because it's not that's important
but here for example this one scale
intensity range this is another
important function
which will change the intensity values
or the intensity range of the of your
images because if you print the maximum
and the minimum value of your pixels you
will find that it is from
not all of them but some of them vary
from
minus 3000 into plus 3 000 others from
minus one thousand five hundred into
plus dollar one thousand five hundred
they are huge values for this case you
can never do a training with these
values you need to put them from zero to
one
okay you need to normalize them but
before doing that you need to change the
contrast because if you don't do any
changing of the contrast and leave them
as they are
the there is no visibility to the images
for this case if you will you do a
training or something like that you
cannot recognize the different areas or
different organs from the image for that
you need to change the
the contrast of your image for that here
i am using because this
b mean and b max are from
what you you will normalize you the
values will be from zero to one but this
a mean and a max will represent the
values that will change the contrast of
your passions let me give you an example
because for me now i am
i as you can see here i am putting a
mean equal i mean a max equal a max
because these are the arguments that i
will pass in this function
for by default i am putting them minus
200 into 200 but i when i will call this
repair i can change them otherwise if i
don't specify them it will take these
values by default okay i put this
because i found that these values are
the most uh the in average this is the
important this is the best ones in the
average but not all the time
but how did i
find these values now i will show you a
simple trick that you can use to find
these values for your specific data so
let's open here etk snap
and
let me
wait
let's choose one of
let's open this patterns for example
now as you can see the visibility is
little bit
we can say normal we can see the
different parts of the body so here we
can see the lever with no problem but
why because i am changing the contrast
if i will not change the contrast i will
go here to tools you need to click in
tools then image contrast then contrast
adjustments you will get this window if
i will click in reset
this is the exact or this is the
the value that you can find as you can
see here for example the minimum is
minus 1000 to maximum is 140
for byte or i don't know what is the
unit for this pixels but the value of
that
pixel
there are some pixels that they are
having the maximum value which is 140
for 1 1400 and others having minus 1 000
etc etc
in this case the visibility is not that
easy
for us we are doing liver segmentation
maybe we can see it but it is not clear
imagine me if you are trying to detect
something like i don't know this one or
something you cannot recognize it
because everything has the same color
for now
so to do that you need to change it and
you can choose you can use these
arrows and try to find something visible
but when i tried this it wasn't that
great but i tried
just changing values here randomly and
for that when i found these
here and here where i found the values
not this
sorry
i found here
here what what you need to change you
can change here values and these are the
minus 200 and the plus 200
if you want to do some changes you can
just adjust these values but you can see
that
the best thing is minus 200 and plus 200
okay and if i will change here you can
see that the values here are changing
okay
but
if if you need if or if you want to use
this for example this
parameter and as you can see here this
one is better than minus 200 okay so we
can't just take this in concentration
but
you you don't need to use everything
that you can see maybe for my data it is
working well but
for other data maybe it will not work
very well for that okay
so
you can do a training with this
otherwise you can just
do do any changes here for example i
don't know
100 and here
for 500 or something and when you see
that the
the image or the
organ that you want to detect is
visible you can just take these
minimum and maximum and this minimum and
maximum are the values where you will
put here
a minimum and a maximum that will be
placed in the scale internship intensity
range
and it will be here for a minimum and a
maximum okay
the next function or the next transform
is this one crop background the
foreground sorry this group foreground
is one of the
i will not say important because if you
don't use it there is no problem but it
is it is one of the useful functions or
the useful transforms because here you
can see that this is the whole image
because it is the black area but
i will just reset here
just make it clear but you can see that
it is a black area but it exists in the
image for that case preferably you need
to delete all these borders that you
don't need and just take this foreground
part for that case this function crop
foreground is
useful for that it will do that
because you can see that
in each function we do here when we want
to specify that transform for the
volumes we call the keyword volume when
we want to do it for the segmentation we
do segmentation when we want for both
we write both of them and you can see
that most of the time we
apply it for every for every
keyword which is for the volume and
segmentation because we want to load the
volume segmentation
channel to the volume and segmentation
change the spacing for the volume
segmentation etc etc but here for the
spacing for example we need to do it
only in volumes because
our segmentations are values from zero
not from zero but values of zero and one
so if you do the if you do some this
these changes you will lose all your
mask because they are binary mask so you
don't need to change the segmentations
for that we write here only volumes
and now as i told you here there is
say the second keyword or second
argument which is source key because if
you use the source key like segmentation
here in that case segmentation it will
be only black alia only something white
in the image so if you do that
it will crop all your
your image and you will lose all the
information and you will get only the
white area or the place where there is a
liver
in your mask and
in the slices where there is nothing in
that slice what i am saying it will crop
all the image for this case you need to
put here source m source key which is
the volume for that case it needs to see
or to look at the image not to the mask
so it will look to the image and crop
this parts and leave only the
interesting parts from the image which
is the foreground okay
now
after doing the foreground here there is
the resize
transform which will resize your images
and masks as well
so that's what what i am using this here
you can
find that there is partial size
this partial size is
what i am putting here in arguments
spatial size is the new spatial size of
your images or the new dimensions so you
can see that i am putting 128 by 20 128
by 64.
here i can put 64 or i can put 65
because our data that we have created
are 65 but i will leave it 64 there is
no problem but you know that you can put
here you need
not you can but you need to put here the
exact number of slices that you have
created so if you have created the same
number as i am
using here then you can use 64. if you
are using more than that you can but you
need to change this value otherwise if
you didn't create the groups as as i was
talking about in few
[Music]
not minutes maybe a few hours before
this part i talked about
maybe you don't need to create the
groups because maybe you have some
new some numbers of slices
almost the same for that case you just
use here or you just need to put the
average number or the minimum not the
average but the minimum number so if you
have you have passions with 4 with 100
slices others with 110 others with 105.
so in this case the minimum is 100 so we
need to put here 100 so all your
passions will be resized into 100 slices
and for the width and the height you can
put anything you want here but you you
need to be um
you need to be careful you don't need to
put something that will make the image
not visible and
you will lose all the information of
your image and i am putting it this
smaller because if i will put it more
than that the training will be very very
slow and maybe will not be accurate
not
i think that if you put it 260 456 it
will be more accurate because i tried
this in another machine not mine
but it will be slow okay but for that i
don't want to put it in my machine
because it will be slow for that i am
using 128 because but if you have a good
machine or good gpus you can use this
you can increase this dimensions of your
images when you do the resize okay
and finally after the resize what you
can do is to
change or to convert these images into
tensors so
this one will open them do all these
transforms and after doing everything
you need to
convert them also transform them into
tensors
you need to be sure that this function
need to be the last function that to be
called because you cannot convert them
into tensors then resize them it will be
an error and you cannot even run it for
that you need to be sure that this two
tensor is the final or yes the last
function that you need to call okay
so
this all what we need to see
but if you go here to the
monas
documentation
you will find that they are they have a
huge number of transform that you need
you can apply but i didn't want to make
it complicated i took only the necessary
ones but if you want to put more you can
put more
and now let's let's talk a little bit
about the data augmentation if you want
to do some data augmentation
then you need to see some transforms
here from the exact page because their
page of transformed here contains the
transforms for pre-process and the
transforms for data augmentation so you
just need to search for it maybe you
just need to search for the word
augmentation or data or notation and
find all the
the functions because i used some
gaussian noise there are some zoom there
are some
flip there are multiple
transformers you can use and i wrote
another blog post about that that you
can see and take an idea about that i
think i have some examples here for
example this is the same passage with
multiple transforms and i have created
all these
uh this one for with gaussian
noise this one shifting this one with
flipping rotation rotation everything
you can find in the documentation and
you can read this blog post just to have
an idea about that
and
and of course of if you need or if you
want to add some data augmentation you
need to add it in the training parts not
in the testing because in the test you
don't need to do any augmentation
augmentation have to be done in the
training so you can find or you can
search for the function add it here and
of course before this to tensor okay
so that's all about the functions
and now let's talk a little bit about
how to do the data loader deci loader is
just to combine between the files
which have which which we have been
defined here
and the uh the transforms that we will
apply to each file or to each passions
so this is the
this is all what you need to know about
the data loader it will combine the
images or the files with the year
transforms and it will apply to
transforms and load them in your
ram and you can use them after but there
is something here which i am putting
here cache this cache i am putting here
in the arguments if it is false means i
will not call it which is i am talking
about this part if it is true i will
call it here but what does it mean this
cache function this cache function
because there is you can use cache data
set or you can just use dataset if you
use this
dataset after what i read and what i
understand is that this function will
load your data into the
gpu memory in that case the training
will be uh
more fast or will be faster and it is
true because i try that with the with
the cash and without the cash with the
cash is faster when i when i say faster
is maybe
five or ten times without the cash but
although it will be slow because even
with this crash it will be slow i don't
know why but
depending to how many percent you have
how many what is the batch size that you
are using and what is the how many
epochs you want to train your model for
that case you it will control your the
speed of your training
but
using this cache will make your training
faster but not all not always you can
use it because if you have a lot of data
and you have a small memory in your gpu
in that case you cannot load it and if
you do it
it will start loading it and in some
point it will give you an error saying
that you don't have memory in your gpu
so you can you may
you can use it or you can try to use it
at the beginning if it works but happy
for you if it doesn't work just put this
cache force or you can just don't touch
it here and it is by default false and
it will
do the training directly we do without
loading any passings in your gpu memory
okay
now after doing everything here what you
need to do just to call it but for now
what we need to do if we just call this
function we cannot see anything we need
to plot it for that i wrote this
function for you i didn't wrote it to be
honest it is i found this from the
moonlight tutorial i just made some
changes and i am using it as
you are
so i didn't do anything by myself i just
did some changes i just write and write
some documentation here because these
are some problems of one eye there is
not enough documentation to understand
what they are doing
and there is no
raising well i am saying raising because
when you will have problems you don't
know what is the exact problem you need
to spend days trying to find or to
figure out what is the problem so these
are two problems with mona if they are
watching this video i hope that
because you are having great
framework but just you need to improve
these things and thank you for that
and now let's talk about how to ch how
to show one passion and of course you
can do it for
multiple passions
the same thing here i am creating a
function called show passing that will
show a passion you need to put in the
parameter here the data loader that you
have in your images so this email this
part as i told you it will take the data
loader which means it will take the
output
or the return of this function i did
this species specifically because i
wanted to make it easy for you you don't
need to write the same code the same
here at the same function here and but
you can just call this function and take
its output and use it as an input here
and it will close your image or your
passions for that i didn't want to use
it as that's
i just want to use it at the same
function here i just made this function
for the preparation or for the
preprocess and this function for the
showing one passes
so this pass this function as i told you
it will just take this data which is
data loader and here we are returning
the data loader for the training and for
the testing for that i am taking here
check passion training check passion to
test because they here this is a list of
two data loaders training and testing
and now i am doing this view train view
test and now what i am doing here this
function
called first it is from one eye this
function first will just take the first
passion from your data loader if you
have 100 passes this one will return
only one pass hint so that you can plot
it or you can do anything you want with
it
so this first function will return this
first passion this first one will return
the first passing from the testing and
now we have two passings to view them or
to show them one from the
from the training one from the validity
from the testing
and that's it i am using here if
conditioned one for
the training and one for the testing
because if you want to see if a passion
from the training
or you want to see a passage from
testing there is no
specific thing because if you just want
to see
your data after pre-process so it
doesn't matter if you see a training or
testing passion
but just i like to put everything here
to make it clear for you maybe you
you want to play with it for that you
can just make this true force or you can
put them both too so you
plot one from the training one from the
validation no problem with that
so
let's go with this here after doing that
just you need to create your figure
and i will put here supplies and as i
told you these parts i took them from
one eye and you can find them in my or
other ways because there is just
something like only pure python just
create a figure figure and before that
this
much plots leave this function or this
package here maybe you didn't have or
you don't have it you know in your
virtual environment or in your system so
you you need to install it i don't know
if i talked about this
or not but don't worry about this at the
end i will at the end i will give you
the requirement.txt that you can use to
install everything but if you are
following the tutorials you can just
install it by pick install
install then mod plot
lib i have it already so i will not
install it and the same thing for this
tkdm function
this function is this library is not
if i can say it is not one of the
important things but it is included in
some parts of the code not only my code
but even in the code of monae's so you
need to install it because it will just
show you the progress so if you run a
loop for loop for example it will be
running the progress or showing you the
progress in which
iteration you are or something like that
it is it is useful sometimes but for now
mona is using it so you need to install
it otherwise you will get an error okay
so just delete this and
now
as i told you after installing the
matplotlib just import it here much
block clip as plt
and for that we are using here
plt.figure to create the figure plt
that's upload to
to supply our figure to divide into two
parts because here i want one line or
one row two columns
and plot this first part in the first
it's first deviation so if you we have
window here we divide it into two
so
one row two columns and this is the
first part where we want to upload the
first passion or the first image and for
for us the first pass the first image
that we want to upload is the volume of
that image which is the this part which
is this volume
and the second part here because this is
the second part will be the segmentation
of that same volume and here we specify
the number of slices not
numbers sorry the slice number so if you
want to print the first slice second
slice and the 64 or 65 slice which we
have in my case if you have more you can
print more otherwise you can even add a
for loop if you want and
bloat every every slice you have or
every passing you have
and you get the point this is for only
one pass into one slice
and if you want to do it for more you
can just change it here as the arguments
of my function i am putting here this is
the required
argument that you need to put the data
loader which is the output of the
preparation
function
then here you need you can specify the
number of slice number otherwise it will
take just the first one and here if you
want to print a training passings or
testing patterns and that's it that's
all what you need now let's
try to make an example about that let's
run this cell by clicking in shift enter
and the same thing for this one and the
last one now everything is set let's do
an example before that we need to uh
we need to return the
passion so i will just take
this part
i will give it in
directory equal
this here
let's
change this backwards slashes because
sometimes it's give an example a an
error so we'll just change them
[Music]
that's it
now after having the in directory we
need to create the passes
so for example i will give it
it is actually it is not passing there
are passions so i can we can put
spacings or i will put only one passing
because we will print only one plot only
one passing so let's just
name it passions without that's s to
make it complicated so passions equal
now let's call the function prepare
which we
called here which we defined here this
is the function prepare as i told you
the first parameter is the in directory
so
we have called it the same thing in
directory for the other parameters you
can change them otherwise if you leave
them as they are
these are the the greater ones that i
found in my case if you want to change
them you can play with them and see what
will happen
but for now i will not change them
because they are great for my type of
data
and now
if we run this there is no problem you
can see if we want to
show one of
the passing that we have so just call
the function show
passions i think this is the name show
passions and now here we just need to
give the passion
as a parameter the other
parts we don't need to to change them so
for now it is one if i will run the cell
it will take few seconds because it will
do the data loader after that it will
show you this passion now let me change
this
name
this number of slices i think it is the
second
we can just
write here for example
five
can see here
now this is the fifth
the fifth slice let's take for example
and that's it's let's try for example 40
and it will be the last one
and
that's it if you want to do more with
that you can just play with this change
the passings change everything you want
and these are the two parts that
that we need to talk about before the
training because there is the
pre-process
and there is the second part which is
the how to show one of your passing
because we need this function for now
and we'll use it after the training to
print the results or to plot the results
so
that was how to do the pre-process how
to show passions
let's talk about now let's talk now
about how to launch the training
we're using one eye and paid off
now
before starting doing the training i
will talk a little bit about the common
problems that you may face because there
are some problems that i found and i
didn't know how to fix them because the
error doesn't specify where is exactly
the problem with my my code okay
so i will show you only three of them
which were common for me but maybe you
will find others that maybe you didn't
install numpy or something like this
these problems are very common and you
can find them but these problems with
monae some sometimes you will not find
any uh
if you go in stock overflow or in even
in monash
repository in github you will not find
answers about this these errors for that
i will just give you these three errors
that i found
not i found but i faced
during my project
and
others maybe if you will find other
problems you may ask me in the comments
or otherwise you may find them in google
because
these three problems are the only pro
problems that i didn't find solutions
after a while doing two or three days
trying to debug the code and you will
see that the error is something very
stupid but you will not know does not
cause the problem okay
so let me just jump to the code and show
you how i will do these mistakes with
you and show you how you can fix them it
is not it's not about fixing them
because you may do everything good at
the beginning and you will not face this
code these programs but i just wanted to
talk about them separately not in the
in the in the code okay
so the first thing is when you put you
did when you put your uh input data to
the path with the directory of your data
if you do something wrong with it you
will face a a problem that i will show
you here how how does it look like the
error
and you may not know that
the problem is your with your path
because
it will not tell you that you have a
wrong directory or this directory
doesn't exist you will not find this i
will show you what is what type of error
you will find and if you will get this
type of error means that you are making
the or you are putting a wrong part or
wrong name of your folders or passings
or something like this
so
here i am sure that this part is true
but you can do a mistake with your path
or
some of the time you can you will not do
a mistake with the path but i will show
you where you can make
or when you can do a mistake because it
happened to me and it happened to a lot
of people
you will get wrong
name of folders for example these ones
because i told you when i shown you
defaults i told you that if you want to
use the same code you need just to name
your folders as mine
otherwise if you want to change them in
your case then you need to change them
even here because you will not get an
error telling you that the problem is
with the names of the folder but it will
not work okay
of course because the part is wrong
so
this first thing maybe you will forget
an s here
you may just write train volume you
forget the s so in that case it will not
work
but it will not tell you that you are
forgetting the s or you are you have the
wrong part
the second thing maybe you have nifty
data not compressed which means you
don't need this.gz
and you are putting it here for that
case the code will search for nifty
compressed files and it will not find
this nibs nifty compressed or zipped
files in that case it will give you an
error
but it will not tell you that we didn't
find this for this file or we didn't
find a complex photo it will not tell
you that so let me just leave it like
this and i will run the code and i will
show you how does the error looks like
so now let's just run this cell
the same thing this cell because i will
try to show an image so that you can see
because if we run only this you may not
find the error because you will find the
error when you call this function which
is this prepare function so when you
call it it will do the operations and it
will find the error so to call it
you can call it you are doing the
training so you may face the problem
during training but for us we didn't
start the training yet so i will show
you
how you can face the error only when you
are trying to plot one off or to show
one of your passions so i run these two
cells
now let's go to the first problem which
is this one as i studio everything is
good here the directory is correct
everything is correct only this
name of passions which are everything
does nii
it should be that gz because for me all
the passings are zipped but i deleted
that so that you will find we see how
how does the error looks like
now let me run this cell
let's wait few seconds so this is the
error that you will find and it is
saying that there is no object
or the
this because
in reality what does it mean it takes
this
data loader which is the output of this
function
and take the first passion from that
data loader and show it but it is saying
that this data data loader or this view
passion is not
it's not talking about the opacity
something called this check passing
which is a
output which is the data loader it is
saying that there is there is nothing in
this list it is like an empty list you
cannot
like doing the index zero index one it
is not subscriptable
so in that case
you will see that
your data loader is empty but there is
nothing saying that the problem is
before the data loader it is not saying
that the path is wrong or there is no
file name that's an i without the easy
it is not saying anything
so if you face this this problem you
will not understand why your data loader
is empty you may understand that your
data loader is empty but why
why it is empty because you forget this
gz
that's it maybe you can put that g and
you forget z so this part doesn't exist
so everything related with the part will
not tell you that you have you are
having a wrong path so in that case you
need to check your parts check your
files etc etc
so
that was the first error that you may
face you may face this error saying that
your data loader is empty in this case
you need to verify before the data
loader
which are the path here
maybe it can be these keywords but for
the keywords i found it give you then it
give you the specific error it will tell
you key errors and it will tell you that
the problem is with the key this is a
good work but if you have problem with
paths it will not tell you so be careful
with that
now let's go to the next
next error which is when you put a wrong
keyword in the dictionary
so we are using here the same keyword
vol for volumes sec for segmentations
imagine with me if i will put here for
example i do it wrong i put two l's so
vol with two else i was writing my code
very fast i didn't see this error
so this
of course i know you are python
developer so this will give you an error
so it will not work but sometimes you
will not see it because i i remember
one time i spent more than
two two hours trying to debug the code
and it was the pro the problem was here
and i remember it wasn't even here
because here it is very easy to see it
it was inside my transforms i maybe it
was here i don't remember maybe it was
here so if you run the code
where is the second error this one wrong
so if i will run this code you will get
this big error and you will get confused
what is this error and i don't
understand what is happening here and
you can see that it is showing you the
uh the arrays of your passions etc and
you
for me i was like what is this what is
all these writings i didn't understand
what is the problem
and the key and the problem is just here
it will give you because for that you
need to read the uh
the error carefully this is not this is
not my case sometimes when i see this
big error i i don't
i just stuck and i don't know what is
happening here
but actually you you maybe you didn't
you don't need to read all this because
you will not understand what is saying
here but if you go just a little bit
here you will see that
uh where is it but it is saying that the
drone is with key error and you come
here to tell you that there is a missing
key which is key was missing which is
this v volume with two l's
so in that case you see that's ah there
is something wrong
and because if you see the last error
here because if you don't read that you
go to the last error you will find that
this is runtime apply and transform
and you see what is the problem maybe i
am i
and it doesn't tell you even here what
which transform is wrong so you may go
to
to all the transformers trying to change
the values that's what i
that's what i tried to do before i
change these values of this big
dimensions or
maybe spatial size etc and the problem
is little bit stupid because just you
are putting an l here wrong and when you
are stressed doing your project you may
not see this type of error believe me i
am saying this because it happened to me
so
but if you read the error carefully you
you don't need to read all this
writing because it's not needed but you
go just here and here it starts telling
you where is the problem and here you
can understand that there is problem
with the key error
then you just go here little bits and
you can see that problem with this
transforms
and of course there is here a keyword
telling you that
the key error telling you that this
keyword is wrong and i think they may
give you even the name of the
transformers where there is the problem
because here it is just telling you that
there is problem with the keyword but
which transform is having the problem
[Music]
i will just see which one if it give you
or not
i don't remember that
transformed because the problem as you
can see here is always telling you that
the problem is with the transform okay
we understand that but which transform
is having this problem
i think that it give you which
transform having this problem but i
cannot see it
um
no no there is nothing talking about
that
keyword dictionary yeah yeah that's it
and you can see we spit spend time
because i know that it exists and i
spent few seconds searching for it
imagine me if you don't know that there
is this kind of errors you will not find
it so you can see here runtime error
applying transform at because at the end
here it is saying the same error runtime
error and applying transform but it
doesn't say which transform is
where which transform is having a
problem but if you go a little bit here
you can see that the problem is with the
spacing the objects transform so you now
you have two uh
two heads or two keywords to see your
problem the first one is you have a
missing key with wrong key which is this
volume with 2l and the second problem is
this you see you know that which
transform is having problem which is
spacing d
and you go just a little bit here
now here and it told you that spacing d
is having a problem and saying second
thing is volume and you see now yeah
this is a problem and you delete this
and the same thing if you have a problem
or we have missing key or wrong key in
other
parts it can be in the training or in
validation or in testing because the
problem
if you have it in testing and you
because all the time when we try to uh
to to say not to say but when we try to
test or to show passions all the time we
use the training passage for that i
added here training or testing if you
need to you can you need always to use
or to test your validation or your
testing data so that you will understand
because here when you will learn to
launch the training because as i told
you i am using the same code of the
training used by monae so in this case
not the same but i made some changes but
you will see that
in this case they will use the
there is a part of which they are
calling it validation i am calling it
testing i told you why
so
during the training you will use some of
data so that you can print or you can
upload some of your uh validation
metrics so we will calculate the loss of
your testing and the laws of your
validation the same thing for both for
them they are not calculating the laws
for the validation but i added it so
that you will get the matrix for both
validation and
and for the notification for testing and
for the training but
in that case you will not see the
problem only when you will run the code
so the code will be run the training
part will run without any problem when
it comes to the testing which is the
validation when it comes to the testing
part it will try to load one of the
passions and it will find that there is
a missing
problem with the part or problem with
the keys or something like this and it
will stop the training tell you there is
a problem and you will not understand
maybe you will not even know that the
problem is with the testing only a key
in the testing part so you need to keep
in mind that if you get some of these
errors maybe this one
or maybe this one
this one like talking about transforms
or something like this you may get only
the last one here you need to check your
key for keywords in your dictionaries
you need to just sure to check your
parts of your data
now after telling you about these two
that is the third one which was one of
the biggest problems that i faced in my
project
when you see doing the uh segmentation
and of course most of the time you if
you because if you do the segmentation
by yourself it is easy and you may not
get this type of errors but if you get a
public data set or someone give you the
public data set with the labels so in
that case you may face these problems
because maybe they are for us we are
doing only liver segmentation
but maybe you will and you will download
data that have been used for liver and
tumor segmentation or liver and heart
segmentation which means two
not two for three classes that is the
background the liver and the heart or
background liver and tumor etc etc
so the data have been used for that case
but you want to use it only for
background and level only
so in that case you you need only two
classes background and foreground which
will be level
but the data has been haven't been done
for that case so you need to change it
you can change it before doing any
training
atk snap i shown you how i have shown
you how can you
just modify uh your segmentation so you
can do it manually otherwise you don't
need to do it because if for example you
have data because if you have data for
liver and tumor and liver tumor
segmentation so the liver the tumor will
be at the same part of the liver in that
case you don't need to clean it before i
will show you only in the code in the
training part how you can just change it
there
but if the problem or if the the yeah if
the error is in the tray in the
for example the data has been made to
segment level and heart for example so
in this case you need to delete the
segmentation for the heart because it
will cause a problem but if the the same
because sometimes even for if you have
data only for labor segmentation you may
get
maybe the man or the person who was
doing the segmentation maybe he did
something wrong
and in some cases
at the same area of the liver he puts
another color or another value or
something like this so two if you have
more than two different uh two different
values so the code will will detect them
as classes so more more values or more
different values you have more the code
will detect them different classes and
that's what happened to me and you will
get the error and you will never
understand that error is happening from
that and i wrote a code a blog post
about that i will just show you
but i will show you how you can do it in
the good the the to fix this problem you
will
you will need to do it in the training
part
not before that because as i told you if
you have segmentations for training and
for the liver and heart so in that case
you need to do it before the training
and you need to delete all the
segmentation for the heart but if you
have the same
you have only one segmentation but with
different values i am talking values i
am talking about the labels because they
are masks binary mask it should be zero
and one if you have multiple classes so
it should be 0 1 2 3 etc each value
represents what's one class
but for us we are having only two
classes so we need only two
values which are zero and one and in my
data here i have problems and i will
show you how
what are these problems i will just
search for the problem
uh yes this one you will get this type
of errors
it is this error is made from by torch
when you will run the code you will get
you will get something like this and you
will not understand what is the problem
you can read this blog post to see where
is the problem and i i have here an
example to show you if you have labels
for example
for us for me i was doing tumor
segmentation so i had two tumors but for
my case i didn't i didn't need to do
instant segmentation which is the first
stream or second tumor i didn't i did i
just needed to know what is the
background and which are the tumors so
they should have the same value and the
same color and here is the problem
and
now i will show you how you can
fix it
so as i told you if you have two
different parts of the body segmented
you need only one so you need to delete
the second one using etk snap or any
software you want to delete that part
otherwise if you have only one organ
segmented but with different values so
you need to put them at unique value
so i will show you one of the passions
that i have where i have this problem so
one of my passions for example this one
has this this problem i will just print
it here to show you
so you can see that this passion here
has two has three different values it
has zero one two
and in my code i will tell him that i
have only two classes the background
which has value zero and the foreground
which has values one
so the code will find these values too
so it will detect them as a third class
but in my code i will tell you that i
have only two classes so in that case
pytorch will have that error which is
this one
what is it this one this error you will
get it and you cannot run the code with
that error so all what you need to do is
just to make a condition saying that all
the values which are
more different that's what i was doing
different to zero i will put them true
because i you can use zero and one or
true and false because you have binary
segmentation so you don't care about
that
so all what i did
zero uh the values which are from uh
different to zero i put them into true
and the values which are zero i put them
into false so that's what happened if
you have multiple classes so you need to
talk about that and you maybe if you
have multiple class everything is good
but for me i have only two classes
foreground background and it is
detecting something as it is giving me
this kind of errors so in this case you
need to change it okay
so that was about the errors that you
may face now let's talk let's start
talking about the
loss function that we will use and we
run the script to do the training
so for the loss function that we will
use we will use the dice coefficient
so that's coefficient which is or we can
call it dice loss because sometimes you
heard about dice coefficients and dice
laws and i wrote a blog post about that
it is this few months ago talking about
what is the difference between them and
you will see that there is no difference
it is the same thing but
you can use it as a metric or you can
use it as a loss function i use it for
both but you will see that it is stupid
doing that but i just used used to both
because
i tried to use because even more like
they are using dice laws for the loss
function and they are using the compute
they just function called compute dice
metric but that's that dice metric the
way they are calculating it it may cause
an errors for me and maybe it can it may
cause errors for you where you when you
you have a lot of empty
as i can see
empty slices where there is no labels so
i
i understand what is the difference
between them and i try to write the uh
not function but it is it's a small
equation in one line to calculate the
dice coefficient from the dice laws
actually we need to calculate the dice
loss then we calculate the dice
coefficients then we calculate the dice
laws but
monae are providing us directly the dice
loss equation and it is working right
good so we can go back from the dice
laws into the dice coffee scenes i will
give you just skew uh
sorry not quick quick uh explanation
about that and you will know that
you can do it even yourself okay but of
course i will provide you the code to do
it
but
here the first thing that you need to do
is to know is the dice what is the dice
coefficient because all of you may be if
you have done segmentation before
or even you have the objective detection
you know the intersection over union uh
value or matrix so dice is not that
different from the intersection of our
union because the intersection of
reunion is the intersection between the
the ground root and the predicted mask
divided by the union the ground root
union
the
predicted mask but the dice value or
dice coefficient is calculating the
intersection here between the
between the ground root and the
predicted mask divided by
the sum and not the union so divided by
the sum and everything you will multiply
it by two
so i will give you this just small
explanation that i have already done in
the in this
blog post so i am just reading it sorry
about that but you will know that these
graphs are more you will you will
understand with these graphs more than
just talking or writing
so let's suppose that we have these two
uh
circles the first one for example a
represents the predicted mask and the b
represents the ground truth that we have
so this is intersection of course you
know it and this is when we say
intersection over the sum multiplied by
2 means that we the intersection is only
this yellow part divided by the sum we
don't care about if they are the same or
not we sum them and here we put the
intersection
so what is the the mean or what is the
meaning of this case when you have or
when you have a good segmentation or
good model means that the intersection
between the predicted mask and the
the prediction and the ground truth will
be almost the same so you will get only
one circle here because they are
supposed uh one uh one over one so you
have the uh
the ground rules is over the
the predicted mask so in this case the
value between them is the same
and
you sorry you will get only one circle
which is in yellow here which is the
intersection between them because they
are the same and in the sum you will get
the same thing because we said they they
are the same so
a plus plus b
is the same thing which we are saying
one plus one two plus two etcetera
etcetera so you will get one thing here
because only one
divided by
one plus one which is two times
a or two times b because they are the
same so you will get two times one
circle or the intersection if you want
to say and divided by two times the same
thing so you will get one so one is the
maximum value that you can get
on the other side if you have for
example the intersection is not your
model is not is very very bad so the the
predicted mask is very um
it is not as the as your predicted mask
so when you do the intersection between
them you will get nothing so it will be
zero so the intersection will be zero so
when the intersection is zero divided by
anything it give you zero so zero is the
minimum value that you can get for the
dice metric and one is the maximum value
that you can get so the dice we are
saying dice metric and not nice laws so
when we say dice matrix so plus we are
more we are closer to one more our model
is good and more we are closer to zero
means that our model is very bad in and
there is no segmentation between the
or there is no intersection between the
predicted mask and the ground root
and
going from this case we can now
choose the or find the the equation of
the dice laws and the dice laws what we
know about dice laws is not like those
what
the laws in general the dice the loss in
general should be closer to zero so more
we are closer to zero means that
the error because the loss is an error
between the predicted mask or the
predicted thing which can be mask class
or bonding box and the input which means
the error between
the output and the input so more the
error is
is slow which means
which which means is closer to zero
means that your model is good or your
segmentation classification detection is
good
now we had only this nice value and this
dice value we said that when it is
closer to one is good and we need to
know and we know that the dice loss more
it is close to zero is good so what we
can do is just to calculate the dice
loss is one minus dice which is dice
coefficient that we calculated so if
this dice is
good which means is closer to one or we
can say one so one minus one is equal to
zero so the dice loss is zero which
means you have the minimum loss that you
can get which will never get it but
the dice law that this dice coefficients
may be the maximum will be zero point
nine nine nine nine nine nine something
like this and one minus zero point nine
it will be zero
zero very good zero zero zero zero zero
one or something like this so in that
case you have a good loss good training
or and good model
so this type of those dice loss we will
use in our case in our training there is
another loss that you can use which is
binary cross entropy laws for for them
in
monae they are calling it cross entropy
dice loss and it is the same thing i
will just give you when we start writing
the code i will just give you how you
can calculate this
cross-entropy because i used it and it
was useful in some cases because when
you are trying to segment for us we are
trying segment level it is something big
in the in the image so we don't really
need this binary cross entropy but when
you are trying to do something because i
used it when i was trying to segment
tumors so the tumors are small area in
the image so in that case when where the
tumor is small area means that
you will get
the number of pixels of the background
thousand times or ten thousand times the
number of pixels or of the foreground
which is the tumors so in this case you
will get you will get a problem called
imbalance data
this problem imbalance data is very
simple from very common in the
classification and we said that
segmentation and classification are
almost the same
but we are classifying each class each
pixel not on all the image so you may
face this problem so you need to use
that binary cross entropy that will
penalize the model when the problem when
the error is in the class that has
minimum pixel values or minimum pixel
numbers not values
so i will just provide you after the
code to do it to do it but we will not
use it in our tutorial we'll use only
dice normal dice coffee scenes and dice
which is and the dice loss but you if
you want in your case maybe you want to
use this binary cross entropy or cross
entropy dice laws you can use it using
the code that i will provide to you
so let me talk to you a little bit about
the cross entropy the weighted cross
entropy that i was talking about when i
talk about the loss functions
so if you have already know what is the
because this is my master's thesis i
just wanted to show you what is the
difference so if you have the cross
entropy
laws that you have seen before or used
before you will see that you have this
equation which is this ground truth
multiple the sum of the ground roots
multiplied by the log of the predicted
mass which is the output everything
divided by or
multiplied by minus 1 divided by n
so this is the normal cross entropy loss
but the weighted cross entropy it's the
same thing but they are adding this w
here which is the weight
these weights are the things that we
need to calculate and i wrote the code
for you to do it you will find just here
in utilities so this code code will
calculate the weights these weights are
nothing but probabilities so if you have
for example 1 million
pixel of black
black pixels which are the background
and you have for example 100 000 of
pixels of the foreground which are the
levels for example level nozzle levels
but level for example so in that case
you will calculate the probability
between them so of course you will get a
probability of pixels or having
having
pixels of background
bigger than probability of pixels having
foreground which is deliver
but this thing here when you want to to
calculate the weighted cos entropy what
you need to do is invert them use the
probability of the black pixels for the
error when you are having uh when you
are calculating the
the dice or the weighted cross the cross
entropy of the foreground
so here let's let's give it a step by
step
so let's say we are calculating the
cross entropy or we can say the weighted
cross entropy so if we are calculating
the errors of the background so when the
model is
is not predicting the background so if
you have background and the model is
giving you that there is a there is a
foreground there so which means there is
a tumor a level but in your case you
know that not you but the label stays
telling that there is no
there is no background there is no lever
there so it should the output should be
a background but the model is outputting
a foreground which is a level so in that
case you need to penalize it out in the
in the back propagation so in that case
because the mother will be penalized
depending to the error so if the error
is big so the model will be penalized a
lot so it will change the weights and it
will be very penalized but if the
problem is in your uh if the error is
small for example 0.001
so the mother will not change the with
all the weights maybe a few of them or
and it will not it will not do a big
change because it knows that your model
is accurate and it doesn't need more uh
changes
but
as you know if the problem if the error
is 0.9 or something is closer to one
means that your model is very bad it
doesn't predicting anything so
all the ways need to be changed and
that's it
updated what i want to say not changed
so
the the idea here is if you have an
error in the background or for us we are
saying background because we know that
the pixels of the background are maximum
of the pixels then the boxes then the
pixels of the foreground which is the
liver because most of the area of the
passions doesn't have a
doesn't have a liver not doesn't have
liver but the liver there is a liver in
specific slices but all the other ones
are empty which are for background
pixels so if you calculate the uh number
of pixels of the background you will
find it ten times not ten times you
playing this hundred or thousand times
than the pixels in the foreground
and even for this how to calculate the
pixels because you will need them to
calculate the probability there is a
code that i write it there for you
i think
utilities
show person yes this one this function
which is calculate pixels it you will
give it the data which will be the data
loader which is the output of your of
the preprocess function that we created
which is prepared so the output of that
function will go to this function and
this function will calculate the number
of pixels which are the pixels of the
the
which which are the pixels of the
background and the foreground so this
function will output an array or a list
of two values the first one is the
number of pixels of the background and
second one is for the foreground which
are zeros and ones okay so
the values that will be returned from
this function you can use them here in
the inputs
of
this so this val you one
which will take the number of pixels of
the background and this value too will
take the number of pixels of the
foreground which are the level in our
case in your case you can you have
something else or the same thing you
want to segment but the background is
the first one the further the foreground
is the second one okay so just to make
it easy because you can inverse them but
you need to know that you inverted them
so the output of your uh
of this function which is the return of
this function will be returned so you
need to take care about that but you
need to
if you want to something clean you need
to write them in the same order so your
first class which is the class with the
index zero needs to be one two to be
here the second one is with the index
one two three etc if you have only two
so zero and one
so this function as i told you it will
return the probabilities but it will be
inversed so of course we have the number
of pixels for the foreground for the
background are bigger than the
background and then the foreground
so what you will do
you will use the probability of the
background
for the error in the foreground so for
example let's say that the probability
of the background is 0.9
and the probability of the foreground
which is delivered is 0.1 because we
need the sum of them equal to 1.
so this one the probability of the
background is 0.9 the the error of the
foreground is 0.1
so what will happen when you are
calculating your error here which is the
weighted cross entropy when you are
calculating the error of the background
you will multiply the error by 0.1
means that your error will not be bigger
so it will be like almost not almost the
same but it will not be bigger a lot
than it is so in the back propagation
when the model trying to update the
weight will not change or change them a
lot because the problem is in the
background and you will not get very big
problems in the background because we
have a lot of pixels in the background
so it will it will be well classified
for that you don't want to update the
weights when the problem is in the
background not not update them but not
change them a lot but when the problem
is in the foreground
you will multiply your loss by this
weight which will be the probability of
the background which will be 0.9 for
example so if we have 0.9 multiplied by
something smaller so
what will happen 0.9 multiplied by
something here the
with the error here or the loss value
will go higher so when the value of the
error will go higher what will happen
the weights or yes the weight will be
updated more than that because they see
that
even doing some updates but the loss is
always bigger so it needs to update it
and to make it more smaller so this is
the road of the weighted cross entropy
it will penalize the model which means
we are when we make the value bigger
means that the mother will be penalized
in the error in the foreground
otherwise if the problem is in the
background it doesn't need to change a
lot of the weights or and it doesn't
need to update the weight
so this is what i understand about that
if you only if you want to read more
about it you can read but that's what i
understand about using this weighted
cross entropy when you have imbalanced
data when you have a class having
10 uh not 10 but 100 or 1000 times
data than the other so you need to do
this otherwise for for the liver
segmentation i used only the normal loss
dice loss i didn't use this
dice cross entropy but if you want to
use it you can just call it as we are
calling this here you can just call it
dice cross
dice cross entropy loss and you give it
the
all the air not the errors but you give
it all all the
values here and it will do everything
for you and here there is a parameter or
an argument would call the weights cross
entropy weights so this quantum weight
will take the weight that as i i was
talking about which will be calculated
using this function calculate weights so
the return of this function will be the
input of
this argument which is cross-entropy
weight so you just give us calculate
weights which is the function that we
have created
and here in the argument of the weight
of this calculate weights we need to
give the values of the pixels which are
the number of pixels of the foreground
and number of pixels of the background
and you can see here for example these
values are from my
tumor segmentation projects so you can
see that there is a difference between
them so you need to use this
cross-entropy
uh weighted entropy uh
loss okay
so
this is the idea if you want to use this
you have just to change these values by
calculating the weights from using this
function
not the first you need to calculate the
pixels it will return the number of
pixels of the background and foreground
then use these values here to calculate
the weights
and the return of this weight will be
calculated here in this will be used
here in this weights chrosotrophy
weights which is this one
so that was everything that i can say
about cross entropy
weighted cross entropy loss now let's
start running this script to do the
training
now let's talk about the training script
as you can see here there is everything
you need to launch your training but i
will go a little bit talking about what
are the difference that i did because as
i told you i took the for loop that will
do the training from one eyes
so i will just which is with this one so
i will just explain few things that i
changed the few things that has changed
are i added a function that calculates
because for them they were calculating
the loss for the training and the metric
dies for the uh for the for the they are
calling it validation i am calling it
testing
but for me i added calculation for
the validation or for the metric of the
training and the loss of the valid of
the testing so i will get four uh
four outputs not for output but four
graphs the first one is the loss of the
training second one is the metric of the
training than the loss of the world of
the testing and the metric of the
testing so and i needed to save them all
because i need to use them for uh to see
to analyze our
our results to see if the model is doing
overfitting and everything or something
something like that
so
and all what you need to know is these
are the arguments that you need to put
to lunch to launch your training the
first the first one is the model which
will be unit for us the second thing is
the in
the data in which is the directory where
you have your data
and yes you have your data and
the
second thing is the laws where you have
which which loss function you want to
use then optimizer and the max epochs
that you want to you to do
for us maybe we launch for 300 or 400
epochs
then the model directory where you want
to save your model trained model
then here there is this test interval
for them they are calling it validation
because they are everything they are
calling its validation i am calling it
testings for that i just called it test
by interval what does it mean this test
interval will
will uh
control in what you know on in which
epoch we want to save the new weights or
the new training weights
what does it mean for example let's just
write here at the end
let's just write for example as epoch 1
we will get
a a loss value for example equal 0.9
okay and we will save this
model or this checkpoint which are the
weights then let's do let's go to the
next epoch which is epoch
okay so in the epoch 2
we will get a loss equal to 0.8 for
example so in this case the loss is
is smaller than the epoch one for that
mean so that means that the weights or
the checkpoints in this epoch
are better than these so we need to save
the new epochs or the new model with the
new ways which is in epoch 2. so we'll
give the order that save
i need to add a comment so save model in
ebook
too
something like this okay then we will go
to the next epoch for example let's go
to the epoch tree
and in this epoch we will get something
like
like for example let's say
loss
equals 0.85
so 0.85 is bigger than zero point
so in this case we can understand that
the model or the checkpoint in this part
or in this epoch are better than these
so we don't i will
so we don't need to save these weights
because we have already better than them
so we'll skip the saving in this part so
what we will do like don't
don't save the model
in epoch
tree
so we go to the next epoch etc etc so
this is that's what's always due in the
in the
in the training but if you are using
tensorflow for example this will be done
automatically if you just clone the
repositories but while doing uh
the training using pytorch you can see
that we are writing all the for loop by
ourself so we are doing everything we
are calculating the
we give we need to give the order to
calculate the to to calculate for
example the first output to pass by the
model then we call the laws to calculate
the laws then we call the optimizer etc
etc
so we as you can see we are doing
everything manually so in this case we
need to do even these conditions
manually
and now
what they are doing they are calculating
this metric which can be loss or even
metric which can be dice for example the
dice value so something like this and
this is what they are using actually
dice and i use the same thing
so this dice they calculate the dice so
more they have maximum value of dice
more than
and in that time they save the the new
checkpoints
but they don't calculate this dice value
for the training
that's why they are calling it
validation indus in the training after
each calculator in each epoch they
calculate the new or the the dice values
of the
testing data which they are calling it
validation data
so when they have a maximum value or
bigger value of the dice from epoch to
epoch
and they calculate it for for the
validation data
or testing data in that case they use
this thing that nothing but they do this
this savings so if this for example i
will go here like
validation or for for me testing data
okay so let's say that the first
the
first dice equal to
for example zero
point
one for example and zero point one is is
bad because we need it higher we need
closer to one so the dice is 0.1 that's
the e-book for example
a book
one okay now let's go to the epoch 2. so
in the epoch 2 if we calculate this dice
it will be for example 0.2 so the model
in this epoch is better than the first
one because here we have the epoch
ctrl c
control v and here we have epoch2
but what they are doing because if you
calculate in each epoch i am doing it
but it will slow your training a little
bit because imagine with me in each
epoch you calculate the dice of all your
validation data so you do the training
find the new model and pass all your
testing data by the model and calculate
this dice value
and
going from that value you will save that
model in that specific epoch or not
so
to give the order if you want to
calculate this dice or to do this
verification in each ebook or in each
two epochs or on each three ebooks or
something like this this will be
controlled by this
what is it the training so that will be
calculated by this test interval they
are calling it validation interval for
them they are using this value equal to
so in each two epochs they calculate the
new dice for all the validation data for
them testing data for us and when they
get higher value they save that
checkpoint for me i used one because i
prefer to calculate in each epoch but
for you if you don't
use that value if you want to fast
little bit your training so you can put
it two or three or depending on your
cases so this value one is by default
but when we will
call the script or the training function
here we can specify it here for me i am
not putting it but if you want to give
it you can just write test interval
something like this and give it two or
three or anything you want which will
change that
value by default
and for me i want to leave it one and
that was all the parameters that you
need for this function
and as i told you there is the first
thing is the model for us we are using a
mono uh sorry a unit but we will import
it from one eye as you can see it is
here monae monae.networks.net imports
units there are other networks but we
are using unit
so there are these three uh
important things that i will i will talk
about the first thing is dimensions we
said that we are doing volume
segmentation which is 3d segmentation or
3d units for that we need to make
dimensions equal 3 for 3d
and the input channel for us it is one
because we have masks with only one
channel i am talking about slice each
slice has only one channel and that
channel have zeros and ones
but the output channels we need them to
be two each because the number of the
output channels is the same number of
the classes that you have so the first
channel will represent the probabilities
or the pixel probabilities for the
background the second channel will
represent the pixel probabilities for
the foreground okay and when you combine
them together you get the new uh you get
the final output so these are the
important things that we need to talk
about these are the chain channels which
which controls how many kernels or how
many filters you want to put in the um
how they call it in the convolution
blocks and these are the strides and
this will create the residual new units
and this one to normalize the batch but
we don't need to talk to you know
everything about that but these three
things that are important the first
thing is the dimensions which is three
for 3d the input channel is one because
we have each slice has only one
dimension the output is two one for the
background segment for the foreground
because we have only two classes if you
have more it will be more etc etc but
others here we have just to call the
loss function here is the dice cross
entropy if you want to use it i talked
about it before
and this loss function that we will use
we are using a sigmoid here
and then the optimizer we are using the
adam optimizer with a learning rate 0.
10 minus 10 minus
5. so that's what you can use for you if
you want to change it you can just
change the values here you can change
multiple to find multiple times or you
can just make that function that's very
which give you an interval of
learning rate and it will be changed in
each epoch on age 10 epochs or something
like this but for me i am putting a
constant number for you if you want to
change it you can change it it depends
to you
but that's all what i will talk about
here
after all what you need to do is just
run this
this script and as i told you that in
this type of training it will take time
it may take two two days that's what
this is strange but it may take two days
depending to your machine and how many
data you have and everything
and that is other things that i have
talked about in the pre-process part
i told you that there is this parameter
which is the cache it can be false or
true
and i told you if we put it through
means that we will use disk function
which will load the data in the memory
of the gpu
otherwise we will not do it so if you
have a good memory you can just hear
what is the data
the this is this function prepare we
call the data so we can just here
make cache which is this
argument and we put it as true so if we
put it through it will load all the data
in the memory of the gpu otherwise it
will be false so if you put it through
it will be the training will be faster
faster than without the cache but
sometimes if you don't have memory you
cannot do it so i will just delete this
because if you we do it i will show you
that it will take time even before to
load the data then it will start
training i will just launch it like this
so that you see that the training will
start after that you can use the cache
if you want
so if i will run this script
you just wait a little bit
and this is because here i am putting 20
for 20 epochs so i will do 20 epochs and
it will calculate the dice train dice
and it will calculate the loss for each
uh image as you can see here and it of
course is starting by a higher value of
loss but it will change it will be
changed
so that's all what you need to do to do
the training so and but you need to wait
as i told you with gpu for me i have gpu
gtx
10 1080 or 1070 i remember
but as you can see here you can define
define the gpu that you want to use if
you have multiple gpus so you can just
change the index here otherwise you can
leave it like this if you have only one
so it will be with the index 0.
so
that's what that's all what you need to
know about the training
and nothing else you need just to wait
for the training until it will be done
and of course here you need to specify
the model dear where you want to save
your model or your checkpoints plus your
plus all the
things which are here the loss values or
the lows yes the loss values for each
epoch and the metric values because we
are doing here a save train loss and
there is a save a book so this will will
save everything that we need so it will
save the new in each epoch it will save
the new values so the first epoch for
example you will get 0.9 the second
epoch it will be 0.3 so it will create a
list containing all the values for each
epoch and it will save them as a numpy
list that we can load after and plot it
to see what was happening in during the
training
so that's what i can talk about you need
to wait for this training if you want to
use google collab it it may work but if
you are having a large number of data it
may take more than 24 hours and you know
that
that google collab doesn't sell for i'm
talking about the free one it doesn't
allow you to to do a training more than
24 hours depending even to your internet
connection it will not if it will not
cut so you know you need to be careful
about doing the 3d convolutions here
using
3d unit it will take time you need to
know that
otherwise there is nothing else to talk
about
and we will talk after the training i
will show you the results that you will
get
and you will see that you we will not
get a perfect result because in medical
imaging you will never get something
like perfect or like in the other images
or other tasks
but you can just see the first results
after that because for me what i was
doing is i made
tons of trainings i
i launched the first one then i i tried
to change something of the data i chose
to try to add more data otherwise uh try
to change the learning rate there are
tons of things that you can change i
cannot talk about them all here but
because i am telling you only the basic
thing and the basic code that you will
find in mulai i'm just transforming some
things here to make it easy
but that's it if you want to make a
better better better training you need
to do these changes learning great or
the the best thing that you can do is
adding more data but adding more data
means that the training will be more
slow but of course at the end it will be
better than less data so
we will wait until the training will
stop and try to analyze our results
so now after doing the training let me
show you some of the results or the
results that i found for my project
so i when i i launched the training i
put 600
epochs but i stopped it as the epoch 100
because i know if i will leave it into
600 epochs it will take time and the
second thing that uh
why i did stop the training at the apoc
100 because i found that here at
i don't know at the apoc 100 before 100
it was in 80 70 something like this
we get this flood here which means that
if we add more epochs of course the
training loss it will go down and it
will converge more than that but for the
validation it will always stay here for
that i didn't want to leave it to leave
the training going more than this
because
we may get a overfitting or we may get a
model which is not very accurate with
the validation of with the testing data
and for that i will i already will show
you one of the passing that i passed it
by the model and i will show you the
results and you will understand why i
should stop the training here okay
so to do it i have this uh
japanese notebook
file that i will share it with you so
that you can test your uh
your model after the training so the
things that you need to to change are
only these two parts the path to the
data and the path to where you save the
model plus these files okay if you
remember when we did the training we
need
in each one in each epoch because i i
fixed the i put the number or the value
interval test interval into one which
means in each epoch it will calculate
the through the training not the
training but you can get the testing
metric
or the testing loss the same thing but
it will calculate one of them but for
for me i did it to to calculate the the
test metric so when i get a higher value
of this metric in that case i should
save the
weights okay
so
i should save the weights which which is
the model but in each epoch i should uh
save the loss trade the training of the
loss uh sorry the loss of the training
and the metric of the training the loss
of the testing and the metric of the
testing in each epoch
so that i can plot it like this and you
can see this evolution of the laws for
the training and these are for
validation
after doing this now let's let's
load one passing or we can load all of
them but i will show you only one
that i prefer to use not prefer but i
will show you how does this look
and you can test your test your final
model with multiple passions otherwise
you may not get the best or the yes the
best or the great the perfect model at
the beginning so you can do more changes
and launch another training okay so for
my 100 ebook it took me around five or
six hours
to be completed okay so you should put
this in mind but but i was i was using
the cache so the so the
data was loaded in the
gpu memory for that it took six hours if
i didn't do that it will take more than
that okay
so
and but it took six hours for only 100
100 apr i stopped it if i left it into
600 epochs it will take two days maybe
okay
so for you if you will launch your
training in at 6 00 60 600 ebooks for
example and if
as the epoch 100 or before that you see
that your model is doing well and you
don't need more training so you can stop
it okay you don't need always to
complete the whole 600 epochs it is a
choice and they are it is a huge number
of ebooks so if you see that your model
is doing great before that you can stop
it okay
now
when you do when you want to load one of
the passions of course you should apply
the same transforms that you applied
during the training and the testing of
course so these are the different
transforms that we applied for the
training and the same thing i will apply
here then we have a test loader because
we want to load the testing files so we
load them and of course you need to load
your model which is the unit
and after loading the model this part
here will load the weights and put them
in the model because you need to create
the model first then put the weights or
two yes to fill the model with your
weights or with checkpoints that you
have you have saved during the training
so this one will create an empty model
this one will put the weights into that
model now you have the model ready ready
model with the weight that you can use
directly for your testing part
so
as i told you i took only one patient to
show you so you can do all the changes
to to bloat or yes to show multiple
passions but you should you need to be
careful with that because the data
loader is not like a list you cannot
just put data loader zero data loader
one extract so you cannot do this you
can do for example a for loop
so you can do for example i will just
write here
for passions for example in
test
loader
this one will will work
and you can use this way for example if
you want to to play to load the first
one so you can just add an index here
for example
i
and here you can put enumerate in this
data loader and you can say if i equal
zero then call this function that will
plot otherwise don't do that if
this is one way the other way that i use
as well which is here
when
what is it here when you select here i
am talking about the test but it should
be test here
for example
so what i am doing here is just
selecting a few passions from your data
set so if you want to show for example
the first one you can do for example
zero to line for example if you want to
show a second one you can just put
from one
two nine then from three to nine two
twenty etcetera etcetera for example you
can put here nine or anything you want
so that's what does it mean you will get
a new list of passions and always the
first person that you will get here he
is the passions that you want to show so
this is one way that i found not found
but you can use this way other thing
that because you cannot do like like a
list like here i cannot i cannot put
here for example this order zero it will
not work and it will give you an error
about that for that you need to find
another way which is for example as i
told you before putting the data into
the data loader select which passes you
want to do the pre before the pre
process you need to select which passion
so you can do that way or the for loop
way that i showed you it up to you but
this is the way how you can do it and
this script will run on it which will
pass each uh
it will pass all this like all the
passions into the model because we said
it is a 3d model 3d unit or cd
segmentation so it will pass the whole
passion which is here 3d the d volumes
which is test volume it will pass it by
all the passing for all the passing for
with the 64 slices it will pass it by
the model here in the model
and it will calculate the
the output or predicted mask and here
this for loop is just to print all the
slices of that specific passion so here
you can see i will show we start from
the wrong segmentation so you can see
here for example for these four
uh
one two three four five six
seven
we can say seven until eight so this
these eight four slices are not well
segmented okay
so you can see that
for these uh the segmentation is great
we i i cannot say perfect but it is
great but for the
the first ones it is not that good
so these are
the things that you need to keep your in
mind in medical imaging you will never
get something uh perfect because you can
see that
we as human and sometimes we cannot
differentiate you can see this and this
part is it not equal to this one so you
can say that this is a level okay but
the model fortunately it is not
segmenting it as a level but you can see
that it is not easy to know which part
contain which is the the exact part of
the human body so you can see that this
is not bad it is segmenting etc but you
need to keep in mind because you need to
do a lot of changes to get more accurate
so you can maybe test these values maybe
you can change the contrast for now you
can put it like this you can do another
training with another values so the
contrast will be changed so in that case
maybe some
some patterns will be better or will
look better than these values for
example so you can try to
changing these or you can the best thing
that you can do is try to add more data
so you can try to add more data you can
change the learning rate
there are a lot of things that you can
do but
and of course you can do more uh
more processing or you can add the data
augmentation that i talked i told you
about i didn't want to add it but you
can add this augmentation and sometimes
it works very well so why i don't want
to try everything because as you see
even only 100 epoch took me 500 500 5
hours
if in my pc so if i will try multiple
multiple trainings and multiple
parameters it will take me forever to
find
the best model so but here in this
tutorial on this course i am just
showing you how you can write the code
how you can
use the different functions in monae but
it up to you to do different changes to
do multiple
combinations to get the best results but
you need to keep in mind in medical
imaging you will never get something
perfect but you can i am sure that if
you do more changes more data etcetera
you will get better than these here for
this part it is good but for example
here it is missing some segmentations
okay and you can test it for other
passions you will find that sometimes it
is good perfect but others is not that's
good
so that was how to do the training
testing how you can as you can see how
you can see your segmentations in the in
the final part what i will do i will
show you just how you can clone the
github repository and use it directly so
maybe you don't need to write the code
by yourself so you can just clone the
github repository and launch the
training from it so i will show you just
in a few few minutes how you can do it
so that you will get an idea about that
now after that we have done everything
step by step
now i am telling
because i told you that i will give you
the code and you will find everything
here in this repository so i tried to
write some sentences here to explain
some of the parts but i didn't have time
to write everything but with time i will
try to add more and more explanations
and of course i am writing some blog
posts about all what we were doing we
were doing in this course so if you
prefer to read instead of watching
videos you will find them but i will
publish them soon okay because i didn't
finish all the blog posts for now so
when i will finish all of them i will
post them in my website
and after understanding what we were
saying now what you need to do is just
to for example if you want to use the
same code that i am using so you can
just clone this repository using this
part here so just go here and click in
this button to copy this line
and go to your terminal
and cd or change directory into your
workspace otherwise if you are using
visual studio code so just open the
folder where you want you to work and
paste it in the terminal here not there
and this terminal and paste your this
git git clone this repository so this
line will clone the repository which
means it will download all the files
that you have in this repository in this
work space i will not do this because i
have already this
this repository cloned as you can see
here so you will get this folder which
contains all the files that you find
here in this github repository okay
so the first thing that you need to do
is to install the requirements so there
is the first thing here
i am putting that
and of course when you do this when you
you can unders this repository you need
to cd to that repository so that you
will your new workspace will be this
repository so that you can oh you can
directly use the code inside that
repository so just copy this cd
like this and copy and paste it in your
in your here in your terminal and it
will go
to the next repository as you can see
here i have already that repository okay
so that
if i will just
make cd
and now if i will paste this cd then
lever segmentation using mona and python
and then it will go
it doesn't go because maybe there is a
problem with that
because i am putting it here wrong
[Music]
so just
correct this spider something like this
okay
so all what you need to do is just to cd
to this directory after doing this you
can start installing what you uh
what we what we used and of course as i
told you about the virtual environment
if you need or if you prefer to install
to create virtual environment or conda
environment you can do it before
installing any packages
otherwise if you prefer to use your
system you can do it directly but i
don't recommend you to do that
so just copy this to install monae after
that all the the other requirements are
will be found here in this file
requirement.txt so you need to install
must not leave numpy
blob
but when you install globe you need to
do group 2 because if you do pip install
globe it will not be installed because
it is not recognizable
then you need to install the control
nifty then this channel but before doing
it you need to
you need to type this keyword because if
you do install chat it will not be
installed and the same thing for me
bubble but don't worry about this you
just need to copy this part which is
this one
pip install dash r then requirement.txt
and it will install everything
then after installing all the
requirements that you need all what you
have to do is start coding but as i told
you there are
some stuff
which you will find here the first thing
that you need to do is to convert your
nifty files into dcoms so that you can
create groups using this function that
you can call with another main script
which will call this function from this
file so you can just do imports create
or from
from what is the name from preprocess
that's pi imports create groups and you
can just use it to create groups using
this function the same thing to do the
to convert from the dcom to nifty and to
find the empty and finally for the
preparation after doing all this stuff
and creating the folders with the names
that you need which which what i mean
with the folder for the volume training
volumes training segmentations testing
volumes and testing segmentations after
that you can just use this function
which is prepared to do the pre-process
and
that's it if you want to do the
if you want to show your passions you
can find the function show in utilities
here
i will go here there is the function i
think it is at the end
yes yes this function
will be used to do the or to show one of
your passions the same thing all the
functions that we were using will be
found
either in this
in this file which is pre-processed the
spy for the pre-processing and all in
the utilities that you will find some
functions to calculate the dice metric
calculate the weights for the weighted
cross entropy and this function train
that you need to do
and finally there is this function which
calculate the pixels i talk about this
as well
for when you if you want to use the
binary the weighted cross entropy you
will need this function and that's it
after knowing everything you just need
to call this function which is train to
to launch your training so for that
there is this file which is
trained as pi which will call exactly it
will call this prepare for to for the
play process and it will call the train
from utilities import train to do the
to do the training using that function
train so the first thing is to create
the model and launch the training so
this
this script is like a main script to
launch the training but if you want to
do the pre-process because if you want
to create the groups etc you need to
create another script called main or
something like that to do all the
preparation
outside your training etc so after doing
the training when you need to test your
model you will find this jupyter
notebook test that's ip
notebook and b
so if you open it it will take time some
few seconds
and you will find everything we
explained
in the previous minutes you will find
them here and just launch this code but
by change changing here the path to the
data and the part to the result or the
checkpoint
and everything will work
and that's it that's all what you need
to know about this
project but if you have any questions
any problems please don't hesitate to
send me emails leave a comment or
contact me by er in social media on my
website pycad dot co i have no problem
answering you answering you but maybe
sometimes it will i will take
few days or day or one day or two days
to answer you if i have projects working
on so please don't hesitate to send
messages or emails and i hope to s to
answer you as soon as possible
so i see you in the next courses if you
have enjoyed this course please don't
forget to thumbs up or leave a comment
and i see you in the next videos bye